you
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows is back
Unleashed unabridged uncensored and
unbelievable only on Sputnik radio
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio welcome to the mother of
all talk shows the Open University of
the airwaves the College of knowledge
well there are no tuition fees and you
are positively encouraged to speak back
to the teacher well the British general
election is ending just like it began
the air is thick with accusations that
it was the Russians what won it which if
you think about it given that it began
with labour accusing Boris Johnson and
the Conservatives of being in the pay of
the Kremlin and it's ended with Boris
Johnson and the Conservatives more
traditionally accusing Jeremy Corbyn of
being in league with the Kremlin over
the leaked documents concerning the
trade talks with the USA I guess that
means President Putin wins either way
actually
unless this turns into a final for long
like no other
since Devon law collapsed at the last
hurdle Boris Johnson is several lengths
ahead and likely to stay in Downing
Street we'll be talking to Manila Chan
the star of RT America about Donald
Trump and Colonel Gaddafi's former
right-hand man about the disintegration
of Libya all coming up fasten your seat
belts
radio Sputnik we speak your language the
mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get free
[Music]
George Galloway
this is radio Sputnik and this is London
broadcasting to you of course all over
the world thanks to the wonders of the
intimate and moskals' famous defenses
are up and ready for our weekly
cyberattack no sign of the attackers so
far at least I think the Kremlin has
seen them off so far so good now it is
the end game of the British general
election and there's no point in trying
to fool you on the basis of the largest
poll today on the front page of the
Labour Liberal inclined Observer
newspaper we're not talking about you
guv we're talking about a serious poll
by a reputable company the Conservatives
are 15 points ahead which is landslide
majority territory although that cannot
take into account several other
possibilities one of which is tactical
voting one of which is people voting for
whoever is best placed to stop or beat
the Conservative even if that party is
not by any means their first choice
neither can I take into account any
last-minute final for long obstacles
that might come in the way of a Tory
victory but has to be said that this
distance if JC wins on Thursday well
it's a miracle and he'll be able to walk
over the River Thames on water and enter
Parliament as the leader of the majority
party I'm going to rule out for sensible
purposes the possibility of a majority
Labour government but a minority Labour
government in a hung parliament is the
best that labour supporters this evening
are hoping for and that of course cannot
be ruled out we'll be talking to the
doyen of cephalo gist's political
scientists professor Sir John Curtis the
daddy of them all when it comes to
elections we'll be talking to him very
shortly
indeed the Sunday Times as part of the
tsunami of bad news some would say fake
news that has dogged this election says
that if Corbin loses on Thursday he will
resign and will seek to install through
the National Executive Committee of the
party his right-hand man a right hand
which has been up his back for the last
few months
operating him john macdonald as the next
leader of the Labour Party just to
organize a leadership election you
understand though if I know John
McDonnell that may take some
considerable time indeed now the tsunami
of bad news and fake news is a real
thing and one of the takeaways from this
election is that you can't trust the
so-called mainstream British media
anyone who does must have their head
buttoned up the back I don't see myself
why any of us should pay to be lied to
to be lied to is one thing to pay for
the privilege something quite different
so I'll be surprised if millions of
people don't switch off and stop by the
fake media which is entirely circular of
course the fake newspaper media run
their front pages which dominates the
news cycle from the review of the papers
the night before through the breakfast
morning shows which all have the papers
spread out in front of them and
dictating their agenda for most at least
of the rest of the day tenders the
carefully calibrated assassination
squads that are out there and not just
on the obvious
issues but before I turn to them let me
give my own report from the front in the
West Midlands on the cold pavements of
the West Midlands labour is dead and
buried the so-called red wall has broken
and all kinds of places that haven't
elected a Conservative MP sometimes
forever
sometimes for half a century are poised
to do so again and they're going to do
so on two grounds
the first is brexit and nobody watching
or listening can say that I didn't warn
them
I warned repeatedly for the last two
years that if Labour boxed itself into
the position of the party that is
blocking brexit that will stop breaks it
that will force you to vote again than
the millions of labour voters who voted
for brexit would begin to melt away like
snow off a dyke and that is exactly what
is happening I'm here to tell you it
it's not because I'm rejoicing in it far
from it
it's not because that's what I want to
happen
it's what I'm telling you is happening
and if you are in denial about that then
you haven't been on the cold pavements
of the West Midlands and the East
Midlands may even be worse as my parts
of the Northwest the Northeast and of
South Wales for labour in those places
it's going to be a bad night of course
in remain our areas a Labour will pile
up massive 30,000 plus majorities
precisely because they are pledged to
have a second referendum to make you
vote again on brexit but I don't need to
tell the clever people at this Open
University of the airwaves it profits
you not to have a 30,000 majority
in one place where you had a 20,000
majority before if you're losing places
that you held not only in the previous
general election and failing to win
places that you had targeted in order to
obtain victory in this general election
the reality is I'm sorry to tell you
that it isn't just bricks it I touched
on it last week I'm going to sharpen it
up this week from the point of view of
working-class people throughout England
I don't think it's different in Scotland
or in Wales but I have no direct
knowledge recently of that for
working-class people they feel that
labour has launched a culture war
against them by forcing them to vote
again on bricks it by characterizing
them as thick lazy stupid northerners
probably racist almost certainly
homophobic almost certainly misogynistic
not properly grasping the nuances of
transgender politics in this modern age
people think that labour doesn't look
like them anymore and labour has
deliberately chosen how it looks all the
time not now and again but all the time
their output the seating arrangements on
the labor front bench the choice of
subjects to run on has far too often in
the last four nearly five years been a
choice that has alienated Labour's
traditional base now it's not that I
want that to be the case I'm telling you
it is the case from my knowledge and I
suspect that you'll agree with me when
you see the results that come in on
Thursday night I'm sure we'll have
plenty of time to discuss that in the
course of the next three hours so let me
leave the election there except for this
the assault on Jeremy Corbyn as an
anti-semite is not just false it's not
just the opposite of the truth it is a
systemic subversion of our politics I
say subversion because it is without any
shadow of a doubt mounted from outside
and mounted in defense of interests
outside you see no one can credibly
point to a single word or action that
Jeremy Corbyn has ever uttered or done
that would be able to be evidence of him
evincing any kind of hostility or any
kind of bigotry or discrimination
against Jewish people in fact the
opposite is the truth but you can adduce
and they are adducing tons of evidence
that he has spent his life standing up
against what he thinks are crimes
committed by israel and what he thinks
are systemic crimes based upon the way
on which the State of Israel was founded
put more bluntly Corbin supports the
Palestinians and opposes Israel and
Israel has had its revenge and all of
its supporters have been mobilized and
people who've never met a single Jewish
person who cannot point to a single
thing that labor has ever done against
Jews are persuaded that Jeremy Corbyn is
anti-semitic and this is organized
militarized mendacity on a scale that
has never been seen in British politics
before whole books PhD theses in the
years to come will wonder at the success
of this campaign it's not been helped by
the way labor faced it they faced
the wrong way from the first day and
they've been facing it the wrong way
every day since including this day on
and Ramon the erstwhile Trotsky a
newspaper seller on the BBC interviewing
the next apparently leader of the Labour
Party John McDonald today john macdonald
more or less final words were we are
sincerely sorry to the jewish people in
britain for the terrible offence which
we have committed against them but
labour didn't commit any offense against
them and as i've put it to you before by
retreating by conceding by capitulating
by rewriting your rules by banning
things that were commonplace from the
mouth of jeremy corbyn himself just five
years ago and by throwing one after
another after another of jeremy corbyn's
closest friends under a bus it's not
just not a pretty sight it doesn't even
work now we'll be talking to the great
manila chan the star news anchor of RT
america in the second hour I think
perhaps third of the show about Donald
Trump who is in his own difficulties now
he's facing an impeachment process that
seems to be going for broke as the
run-up to the u.s. presidential election
looms the American primary season is
about to begin
they're determined to put their
adversary out of action before they
reach polling day as well they might
because if they pick any of the
favorites that there are currently
predicted to pick well Donald Trump will
beat them again and we'll be talking to
the former right-hand man of Colonel
Gaddafi the erstwhile leader of
his spokesman dr. Musa Ibrahim became a
household name and face as the old
regime in Tripoli Wars falling and the
new terrible terrible power was coming
into office or rather three offices at
the last count there were three
parliaments in Libya for prime ministers
don't ask me how that works now Libya
wants the richest country in Africa is
disintegrating in front of our eyes has
ceased to be an effective state not a
failed state but no state at all we'll
be talking to dr. Musa Ibrahim about the
tragedy of Libya now if you're watching
us on Facebook as record numbers of you
are please share the show with all your
friends on Facebook as we chase that
magic number of 1 million viewers and
listeners in part or in whole of the
mother of all talk shows you can also
watch on youtube on my youtube channel
or artis and on facebook on my facebook
and artis multiple platforms you can
even watch us on Twitter as a record
number of you did last week the audience
for this show notwithstanding the
cyberattacks is on the up up up now
here's our first poll of the night who
will win the general election on
Thursday a Labour be the Conservatives
see a hung parliament you can vote now
on my Twitter feed at George Galloway
the pool closes at 9 p.m. no sir John
Curtis has been right about many things
in his long and distinguished political
science career he should be in the House
of Lords if I had the power to put him
there I would but then he probably would
turn it down he's that sort
of a guy he reads the runes he studies
the poles he analyzes the trends we just
look up all on a page in a newspaper and
move on he digs underneath and locates
the way the wind is blowing and I hope
he's on skype with me now professor Sir
John Curtis welcome back to the mother
of all talk shows good evening George
no sir John the the big poll this
morning was the observer poll it made
pretty grim reading for labor supporters
tell us first please how you saw that
poll and then we'll move on to the
trends that you're detecting elsewhere
yeah the opinion poll in the observer
was one of four polls published this
morning it had the Conservatives 15
points ahead but that in truth is what
opinion was saying a week ago the PDM
have now emerged in this election as the
pollster that's turning to produce the
largest leads for the Conservatives and
therefore from a neighbor perspective at
least is producing the least comfortable
numbers other polls put the lead while
the smaller one as low as eight others
around the nine ten mark and the average
lead for the concerns in the polls is
ten points in the polls have come up
this weekend
now that's somewhat less from the
Conservatives were enjoying two or three
weeks ago but it's pretty much back to
where we were at the beginning this
campaign the only difference being that
during the campaign both the
Conservatives and the Labour Party have
made progress in both cases by about
five points or so the net effect of
which is simply to leave the
Conservatives they had where they were
it's simply the Brixton party who
suffered by being squeezed by the
Conservatives and the Democrats who on
the remain side of the brexit argument
have been squeezed by the Labour Party
those kind of poll numbers ten point
lead or so if the average is correct
conservative mature seats about 350
majority of 50 couple of other exercises
that came out this morning which
don't annoy statistical analyzing of the
data using a much much favored method
for doing so once in 3/4 for the other
said 345 so all of the data at the
moment are pretty much all the data are
pointing to some kind of conservative
majority though not necessarily one
that's guaranteed because the
Conservatives need probably more than a
six point lead to get an overall
majority so 10 points is not so far
ahead of that that they can necessarily
sit comfortably and we do have to
remember insofar as this election is
about brexit that there is no other
party likely to win seats in the House
of Commons that's willing to vote for
Boris Johnson's deal as is currently
constituted so the Prime Minister fails
to get a majority that his deal could
well be dead as dead as Theresa Mays
Ward was beforehand well we'll come on
to what that would mean for for next
year presumably it means another general
election but before I go there 10 points
is I know this is a very unscientific
thing to say to a scientist to viewers
note but 10 points feels about what it
is to me that's my anecdotal my daily
experience is that yours or are you
shocked the temper look George I don't
think any political scientist who spends
half his life in Scotland and the other
half of the campaign in London both of
which are ardently remained parts of the
country could necessarily be said that
anecdotally they've come across the
cross section of the UK population that
said what he does fit is is quite a lot
of the box pops the interviews one is
heard with interviewers with people I
via the media I particularly would point
you to a program the BBC Newsnight it
accompanies going interviewing people in
Wakefield or indeed a story that's in
the Sunday Times today interviewing
people in the working men's club in trim
done where you're getting people who are
saying that their lifelong labour voters
but they voted leave and there are
set about the fact that brexit hasn't
been delivered and they've been
persuaded by Boris Johnson that labor is
part of the obstacle to the delivery of
brexit and they are saying they are
going to vote for the Conservatives in
some cases for the first time in their
lives and there is undoubted as a wall
of seats out there from north east Wales
through to Ashford and Nottinghamshire
up to Durham across the cumbia worth
working to see so traditionally just
being basically safe labour seats but in
the wake of the brexit votes won quite
strongly the Conservatives in 2017
although the Tories didn't make quite
like to pick them up but there are now
marginals and if these polls are correct
then these kinds of seats are now
potentially vulnerable so it's they
frankly a potentially quite serious
break with the Labour Party amongst a
section of older pro leave traditional
working-class labour voters where the
party's in trouble in the contrast one
suspects there are parts of the South of
England including not least London where
the party might find yourself in much
less difficulty any big sculpt that you
could predict would go if this fall
these polls the average of them today I
mean the will there be a part illo
moment for anybody based on what you
know so far well the nearest I think we
expect to a porter moment is probably
Zac Goldsmith in Richmond Park not that
he's somebody whom the Labour Party have
in their sights but rather theatres were
Democrats though broke routes actually
beat him in a by-election in 2016 and
then he regained it again in 2017 he's
not in the cabinet but he's and he's a
relatively senior minister and he's
probably the most senior person who is
definitely like here on the top given
the average of the polls there are then
wanted to other potential notable
casualties in those labour leave held
seeds of which perhaps the most notable
is potentially Denis you know the so
called beast of Bolsover or who if he's
elected now and his well into his 80s
would become the father of the house in
following on from Kenneth Clark but
there's no guarantee that he's going to
get elected given when the polls are
otherwise the far as big beasts are
concerned we're just looking to see
whether or not something happens against
the general tide so for example Ian
Duncan Smith another arch brexit here in
North London his constituency is
becoming more Pro remain is he is he in
danger nothing to do with the average of
the of the polls but the Liberal
Democrats are trying very hard to
dislodge the very Pro brexit foreign
secretary Dominick Rob in Isha and that
he's trying to defend a very Pro remain
seat and there are one or two other key
battle very su ideas battles in London
for example trick or munot the former
shadow labor cabinet member who is now
fighting for the rail cars having
defected labour over brexit he's trying
to win the City of London and
Westminster South and the absolute heart
of the capital not somewhere that's
traditional democratic territory but
very Pro remain territory the Indy
Polling's been done like especially
suggesting isn't going to make it but it
certainly is unusual to see the dugouts
strike challenging strongly in parts of
London that hitherto frankly have never
really been much of importance at all
what about the likes of Yvette Cooper
and Ed Miliband in the north would they
be down on on these kind of swings they
might neither of them have
constituencies on the look as though
they would potentially go there one of
Ed Miliband's neighbors Caroline Flint
who although originally Pro romaine has
been one of the Labour MPs most willing
to vote in favour brexit indeed voted in
favor of Boris Johnson's deal on the
second reading back in October she is on
the list of people who could potentially
be casualties
despite her personal record on the
subject now this is a question I could
looked up for myself but save me is the
party that's leading on the final Sunday
usually the party that wins there or
canned Monday Tuesday Wednesday of this
week actually bring about any change
based on historical experience that's
sure I mean usually it's the party
that's ahead that's going to win
inevitably I guess the one election
which we know that clearly
wasn't the case though in those days
polling wasn't done as close up to the
final day as it is done now and that was
back in 1970 when Edward Heath dislodged
Howard Wilson that certainly wasn't an
action that saw a late swing you might
also want to add February 1974 when
Edward Heath then lost a Howard Wilson
there was certainly a movement fairly
late in the campaign and of course in
2017 labour certainly gained ground
fairly late in the campaign although not
enough to stop the Tuohy's some still
being the largest party so yeah only
movements can't happen but not always
and I meant but I think here again we
come back to the point George is that
this isn't simply an election about
whether or not the Conservatives win
it's an election about whether or not
they get an overall majority and that
therefore it's not that they do actually
have to do better than Tory summated in
2017 if Boris Johnson is going to
achieve his objective and if he doesn't
get a majority then even though he might
have more seats on labour he could still
find himself being served out of 10
Downing Street now might I have the
temerity the lessee majesty to oppose a
question like this you predicted at the
beginning indeed on their sure you
predicted it yeah that there would be
that the the two big parties would have
far less dominance in the new Parliament
than they'd had for a very very long
time
and that all kinds of smaller parties
and so on would be in the house would
you revise that now based on what you
know I'm quite happy to acknowledge that
the forecast is not as certain as it
once was that said well first I mean
first of all the force of my point is
still probably likely to be there in
that if you take the current polls for
example I mean the record number third
party MPs is 88 we at the moment might
get 82 so it might be cited s but it's
still going to go on the high side
frankly much reading out depends on a
month at whether or not I'm going to be
proved right or wrong it's going to
depend primarily on the fortunes of the
were Democrats the SNP in Scotland who
are a crucial part of that forecast
their vote is certainly holding up the
polls various - exactly how why they're
doing
but all of them have them are all of
them suggest they're going to make gains
and that should Denise be perhaps around
41 42 SNP MPs but maybe a few more
the real question is will the democrats
end up not much more than the twelve
they got last time in which case my
forecast is going to be wrong or do they
end up with clearly more than the 20
seats that they had a dissolution in
which case I could still be right so I
my fate is in the hands of the road
emigrants
which we might sorry the safest decision
it has to be that's not the the most
studly nil to hang your jacket on in my
experience Sir John you mentioned the
SNP and Scotland it's a paradox isn't it
because there's a poll this week shows
support for Scottish so-called
independence Scottish breakaway
considerably down four points or more
down on what they got in the last
referendum in other words a Scottish
polity which is more Pro Union but
likely nonetheless to elect more
separatist and peace well market-based
and what's been going on in Scotland
till the last couple of polls there's
one today one yesterday the polls have
been showing a clear increase in support
for independence was compared with 2015
running at about forty nine percent then
we had a poll that was released on
Saturday that had it down at forty three
and another one today at hazard at forty
seven so it does seem to slip back a bit
but bear in mind that I mean even though
the SNP are doing relatively well we're
talking about poll figures of between 38
and forty four percent for the air
support for the SNP so the level support
for the SNP isn't simply synonymous with
a level of support for independence and
to that extent at least we shouldn't be
surprised and we get a bit of a
disjuncture I think once now it's still
true about the position of Scotland even
though perhaps the numbers of ease is
that support for yes
amongst remain voters is still up on
where it was twelve months ago it seems
to have been amongst no voters that the
decline in support
leave Otis the decline support has
happened and that therefore insofar as
one of the findings in the last 12
months has been that people's attitudes
towards independence is now more clearly
linked to their views about the brexit
than they once were that force that
potential force that if indeed the UK
does leave the European Union that as a
result may be support for independence
in Scotland with garbey up further
indeed today's polls suggest that it
would be a majority friend opponents if
the UK leaves the European Union on the
31st a journey and I think certainly if
there is a conservative administration a
majority conservative ministration this
pursued black students wanting to say no
to a Scottish independence referendum
shall we say I suspect that ideology is
going to have to be replaced with
statecraft if indeed the UK government
is going to maneuver things in such a
way that Scotland doesn't want to sue
for independence because it's certainly
going to be quite difficult to avoid a
situation where a the SNP together with
the Greens win the scholarship election
in 2021 and the pols perhaps beginning
to show that there is a majority for
independence north of the border just in
paranthesis the Liberal leader will she
hold our seat in Scotland in your view I
expected to do so I mean her opponent
and the person who defeated her in 2015
John Nicholson has come to the
conclusion will be better to fight
another seat and he's gone off to Arkell
and I you know actually by the standards
of Scotland Josef ensign has a virtually
safe seats the Liberal Democrats are up
it's not clearly a seat at the SNP are
heavily targeting so I wish I would be
surprised if she were to lose that since
she's got quite a substantial personal
vote amongst other things in that
constituency now let's finally and I'm
grateful for your time the the election
result a majority for the Conservative
Party not the kind of majorities you and
I have known before a hundred the
hundred plus that both Blair and the
Conservatives under mrs. Thatcher and de
jure major got the biggest ever
conservative party vote in in 1992
let's assume though a working majority
laborer with that breach that you talked
about with the traditional section of
its of its base presumably looks for a
new leader we learned from the Sunday
Times today that the interim leader will
be John McDonald and knowing John
McDonald as I do that might be quite a
long interim eventually what was labour
going to have to do or can it do
anything to the pay of that breach well
I mean brexit husband out he calls low
productivity it's kind of widened uh
attention that's always been there
between its more traditional more
working-class support that tends to be
wealthy socially conservative concerned
about issues about immigration and which
is I'm which has been loosened from the
party's grasp as a result of brexit a
much of its newer support I mean the
party does very well amongst younger
voters particularly on graduates
socially liberal folk and that tension
is going to be difficult for them to
resolve for so long as our relationship
with the European Union and the issue of
immigration is central to the UK
political agenda and although the Prime
Minister's promising to get brakes done
by the 31st of January Breck's is not
going to be off the agenda quite that
quickly so that is a problem facing the
party we could well see labour doing
relatively well in London
nothing like so well in its traditional
heartlands the north of England and the
middle name is going to have to sort
this out I think most immediate the
debate is going to or that the argument
and the battle for Paris other party is
probably going to be between a nominee
who is reckoned to be close to Corbin
and the ideas that jeremy corbyn's been
trying to pursue so somebody like me
back along with Allen Bailey or perhaps
Laura petticoat or is it going to be one
of those less left-wing members of the
party but who have been loyal to Corbin
and have remained inside the shadow
cabinet people like hear sama or heavily
Thornberry who are perhaps bother more
to the center of the party and it's a
question of which of those two
directions labour decides to take
the day laborers real problem however is
it's going it's not so much its policies
being too left-wing or whatever much of
what the Jeremy Corbyn and his
colleagues of trying to espouse are
quite popular that differ they have
faced is they haven't been able to
swayed people that Jeremy Corbyn is
somebody who could deliver that agenda
indeed can deliver some very traditional
things like running the house service so
the party above all has to find somebody
a respect of what wing they're on it's
actually capable of convincing people
that they will be capable of being this
country's Prime Minister our Paul John
for what it's worth so far 35 percent
think labour will win 44 percent think
the Conservatives will win and 21
percent think a hung parliament
that's an interesting because you're
[ __ ] much more optimistic for labour
than I would be I think to be honest
Labour's chances of winning an overall
majority are virtually zero professor
Sir John Curtis I take my hat off to you
metaphorically of course
and I hope that we can talk again after
the polls and we can see who was right
and who was wrong it's usually you I
know thank you very much indeed
professor Sir John Curtis now earlier
this week I did my usual short for RT it
was in the wake of the terror attack
that took place on London Bridge if
we're ready for it let's take a look now
at that
the terrorist mother our Islamist
fanatic Osman kin is surely now burning
in one of the circles of hell and that
is the best place for him before I go
further I need to make this clear
the only good Isis terrorist is a dead
one and we have to kill them everywhere
that they showed their ugly death cult
faces but a number of questions arise
from the London events on London Bridge
on Friday which are not so easily
or clearly answered first of all the
half ago heroes who disarmed this
terrorist murderer and thereby saved the
lives of an unknown number of people it
said that can even had a gun in a
plastic bag as well as two knives and
what turned out to be a fake suicide
belt the half ago heroes except in one
case a Polish chef we're all themselves
convicted criminals and prisoners on day
release or on licence and one of the
most heroic of them was himself not that
long ago convicted of an horrific and
absolutely unprovoked murder of a
disabled young girl food for a lot of
philosophical discussion in that one but
the government have questions to answer
to why was Osman can able to be released
from prison less than halfway through
halfway would have been bad enough the
16 year prison sentence he was given for
being in our Qaeda cell which was
planning to blow up amongst other people
Boris Johnson then Mayor of London he
planned to blow up the houses of
parliament to blow up the stock exchange
and other
of the city secondly he was wearing an
electronic tag which we now know means
absolutely nothing at all because if
wearing an an electronic tag you can go
to the scene of the crime you were
convicted of planning and conspiring
with al-qaeda to commit then who's
monitoring the electronic tags there he
was in the city of London that he had
been in prison for intending to blow
sky-high the third point is how can
anyone believe the protestations of this
death cult when they write letters to
the authorities saying that they are now
wholly reformed from my point of view if
we must imprison them rather than kill
them they have to serve the entirety of
the sentence that they are given we
cannot afford a liberal civil rights
namby-pamby approach to this question
but other issues I'm afraid cannot be
avoided I have made five hundred maybe a
thousand speeches on Britain's foreign
policy and how it has contributed to the
cascading of this fanatic Islamist
extremism all over the world in this
short video suffice to make one point
I've made many times before if US man
can had taken his gun and his two sharp
knives and a real suicide belt and gone
to Syria to murder Syrians well the
British government would probably have
paid his fare because we have spent the
last nearly ten years actually putting
knives guns money propaganda and
intelligence support in the hands of
people exactly like Guzman can on the
immoral prints
told that my enemy's enemy is my friend
well your enemy's enemy might be even
uglier than your enemy and by making
your enemies enemies stronger
of course it's certain that when your
enemy's enemy comes back home it's going
to be looking for people here to murder
so food for thought of course from
London Bridge on all kinds of levels the
government have some explaining to do
about how can't manage to be on London
Bridge in the first place
the rest of us have got some
soul-searching to do about the fact that
even mothers even hardened criminals can
do good sometimes and we as a country
have got to ally with all of those
around the world who are fighting to
destroy Isis and al-qaeda there is no
point and no case for opposing Isis on
London Bridge but supporting them in
Aleppo and Damascus have something to
say do you disagree with George then
call us now and give us your view record
numbers of viewers and listeners again
and it's only quarter to eight spread
the word that we're on and what we're
talking about the poll I gave you thirty
five think labour will win
professor Sir John Curtis thinks the
chances of a Labour majority are
practically zero
the Conservatives forty four percent of
you think they will win and twenty one
percent think it will be a hung
parliament all kinds of emails and
tweets let me get through a couple then
we'll take a couple of calls I see John
major is making headlines again what is
it with these people he came he wrote he
was disgraced but he really does
struggle with the need
simply retire somewhere and leave the
rest of us alone very very interesting
us from James when I saw John Major and
Tony Blair together this week straining
straining to try to stop brexit I did
wonder if it might have the opposite
effect Tony says labor became an
Islington cabal and forgot their roots
they're more concerned about identity
politics the rest of us are too busy
working to make a decent living to be
bothered by such things breaks it will
ruin labor and Manfred this is an
interesting one been trying to contact
you for weeks to let you know you have a
following here in Havana Cuba where a
bunch of us expats I'm from Australia
despite the German Monica others are
from France and England watch you every
week on YouTube I would gladly follow
you to the barricades you've asked the
ultimate test for us keep doing your
wonderful unmasking of the filthy rich
and their lackeys in your inimitable way
we love you made from Manfred in Havana
Cuba can't tell you how nice that feels
thank you so much let's hear from Kieran
in Herefordshire Kieran the floor is
yours
thank you yes a couple of points really
and I think the first one is why people
should vote for Corbin that having
doubts
I could put directs it to one side for a
minute I think anyone from Labour or not
sure you know the middle somewhere I
should vote voting for Christmas I want
men in a chair I think people should
really ask themselves do I want to keep
the NHS or go Mike if they vote
conservative it's between the ten-year
trend of selling that office than it
continues that is one reason the less
shouldn't vote for the right people
reason why the right should maybe think
about voting for Jeremy Corbyn Jeremy
Corbyn is the only one
absolute legend have the courage to tell
the war mongers in the Middle East where
cash of their war within that I think
what happened one of the reasons for
this whole anti-semitism business was
directed at Jeremy Corbyn I think partly
back to what impale is saying that the
Americans are intervening in our
election to stop Corbin being elected
and he was speaking to a group of
Zionists funders and the war with Iran
is much less likely to happen and if it
does if it doesn't happen we won't be
flooded there won't be any more ways of
the asylum seekers and refugees that the
right claim to not want particularly
living less like an asylum seekers and
refugees so you know there's two under
this time brother George I'm shutting up
mark this is I think the whole Middle
East war thing has been a mistake the
labor shouldn't have left it out I think
they should be speaking about it if I
can be the only one trusted can make a
war will be right less likely and asylum
seekers less likely well there won't be
many takers for that in Herefordshire at
least the last time I was in
Herefordshire
how many labor votes are going to be
pulled there do you think Gearin sorry
Georgia is actually hot but you not help
it you Department actually that's what
it says it's my fault I'm so sorry
so the the the point I was trying to
make is that if neighbor is losing in
its heartland and therefore by extension
one must infer
will fail to make a breakthrough in its
target seats the seats it didn't win
last time then and not making progress
in in rural play I saw for example Jacob
Riis MOG
they had some polling in his area and he
looks to be miles ahead
so Labor's going to consolidate its
strength in pro remain areas better off
areas paradoxically of England it's not
going to do well in Scotland it's a poor
distant third in Scotland
it's ahead in Wales but it used to be
it's both in Wills rather than count it
and it's not ahead in Wales by all that
much and for example Wrexham which I
think has never been a conservative seat
the polling there shows the
Conservatives miles ahead so why do you
think the arguments for voting labour
which you have just Adam grated have
failed to make a breakthrough what
happened okay with the newspapers and
banging up the way that happened not
only is the message which only Gordon
already lost who is going to be the next
leader what they've done is brilliant
and I play to only labour voter
listening to this just a passenger in
this rather inside the EU an NHS I'm
sorry but that's a false dichotomy the
NHS has been being privatized not for 10
years but for 25 years and in not 25
years we've been inside the EU really
had a genuine Labour government if you
count the labour which is totally a
truly like the EU that's my point
stop privatisation it worships
privatisation
okay I take your point on that one but I
still think it's less likely with a
genuine labour of course it's less
likely with the Labour government but
that's a respective of whether or not
you're in the EU it was that false
dichotomy I was challenging Kieran
thanks for the call and my apologies
about mixing up the County
I'll not mix the next one up it's from
Portugal it's matt in portugal go ahead
Matt but salam-o-alaikum George well
they come salam how are you doing I'm
good then nice to hear from you
likewise go ahead the floor is yours
yeah well I suppose the practitioner I
was wanting to talk to you about because
I'm now a portuguese citizen I decided
to remain because my family is European
my daughter's European and my my parents
both live in Europe as well so I've sort
of taken this big decision to physically
remain in Europe with disregard for
anything that any poles or any any sort
of like politics in Britain has got to
say because my political stance has
never been like from a British
perspective I owe more allegiance to
like for example the five star movement
in Italy or the block or disk era in
Portugal and the the indignados movement
in Spain where I have been politically
active but I also have participated in
the European social forum and the world
Social Forum which are know started in
Brazil in the year 2000 but when I
participated I went to Senegal in the
year 2011 so I made some sort of
political propaganda and helped to
organize some sort of like international
movement
sly on different levels but what I don't
really understand with this brexit issue
is that like we're talking right the
European Union is a subsidiary of the e
the UN right so the British government
then would be a subsidiary of the EU so
where does the g8 fit into all this
I mean I went to protest against the g8
in Evian in 2003 or 2002 before the Iraq
war broke out and I went to the g8
protest in rocks stock Rostock in
Germany Matt this is a fascinating
toward the horizon-- but can you can you
come to a point that I might address
yeah well I mean substantially then like
what like if i if the EU is a subsidiary
of the UN I don't understand even what
that means what do you mean a subsidiary
well I don't really understand what this
or like the political dynamic is like
it's like like the g8 is that like where
the decisions are made that affects
their international perspectives or is
it the UN do you see what I'm saying
this is the Americans it's something not
the the UN of course the short answer to
you is it's no longer any of your
business whether Britain leaves the EU
or not because you've already left us
and are now a citizen of Portugal but I
would never read that to our fine man
like yourself thanks very much for
calling let's hear from Kevin in Suffolk
Kevin welcome hello my nice to talk to
you right I'll try and be quick I don't
want to take up too much time I've been
on a long journey I'm in my fifties my
grandparents were like Labour Party
organizers in the
and I you're not going to like me George
I gave up on labor in the 80s I I'll be
I've thought I was a Tory basically last
week I listened to an interview with a
guy called Maurice Glasman and that guy
was a revelation
he's a very big man yes he's the he's
the Guru of blue labor well exactly
okay I didn't want to use that phrase
because that phrase I think was off a
lot of people but what he's talking
about is the betrayal of the working
class by command what they were called
but it's a middle class we get your
point you had one yeah basically okay so
now makes the casting of the name but
anyway so basically you know what ended
up with Blair has taken over the Labour
Party and was was in the process of
doing it over the previous sort of 4050
years even under le we got Roy Jenkins
and his ilk in the 60s and I think you
know totally the wrong policies have
been followed it not you know
immigration is a touchy subject but the
only way to do it was was to allow the
kind of assimilation or not assimilation
but the kind of coming together of the
communities has happened when the Jews
came here in the late 19th century and
he ended up so the Jews are part of the
British tribe that should have been done
with the immigration that happened after
the war and we followed this
multiculturalism we followed all these
divisive policies that I saw our nearly
swore that have messed up this country
just beyond belief you know it's just I
don't know I just I just really like
listening to that guy and I really feel
connected again I felt connected to like
my roots and and you know I don't think
I've
once actually a few times on Twitter
George and I don't go along with you on
a lot of what you're saying but I think
like you're part of the solution I don't
think Corbin ever ever came close to
being part of the solution for anything
and we could have a conversation about
that but I do I do think that the the
culture war point that I made earlier is
valid and it doesn't cut across anything
that Glassman will have been saying the
the truth is labor has different
priorities in how it looks at life and
looks at the country to millions I don't
know how many millions but definitely
millions of its traditional
working-class supporters and labor on
its front bench and and the people that
it puts on television and so on it no
longer looks like the party that it did
even when I when I joined it there are
no James Callaghan there are no Denis
Healy's there are no Tony Ben's there
are no Michael foots the Alliance that
the Labour Party used to be of
working-class people with middle and
even upper-class intellectual allies
making a coalition for change for
progress no longer exists
working-class people like Ian Lavery a
former miner - Union official are
essentially treated as mascots by
today's Labour Party
he's never sitting next to Jeremy Corbyn
on the front bench it's it's Don Butler
and Diane Abbott and I'm not sure what
point is attempting to be made there
certainly when it's every single week is
the point that look at us we've got
black women and prominent positions good
ol but you don't need to make that point
every week you might change it a bit mix
it up a bit after all 88% of the people
of Britain are not black and half the
people of Britain are not women and so
you might bring Ian Lavery and I don't
know Richard
to sit next to you on week two and you
might mix and match up with people who
are not London MPs as both Butler and
Abbot are did you see the point and
making the output from the Labour
Party's Twitter feed and so on is far
more likely to be on liberal and
identity not in the election by the way
I think they've done quite a good job
during the election in the material that
they've been putting out but in the four
years before the general election they
were not so good do you see the point
I'm making Cameron George absolutely
learnt the point the point with Diana
Baur is not that she's a black woman the
point is that with all due respect
she is just ludicrous that she's in the
position she's in she hasn't mastered
the brief you know if you've got a black
person the black woman whatever who is
competent and authoritative and natural
you know I mean I'm not an Obama fan but
you know that guy absolutely controlled
the narrative you know I mean it's you
know that's still beside the point but
don't worry it's been a really
interesting call Kevin I hope that we
continue it either on Twitter or on here
I've got to take a break now
unfortunately for the news but here's
the poll at the moment
36% if you think there'll be a Labour
win in the general election
let's thought if I present more than not
as 36% more than Professor Sir John
Curtis predicted that's gone up one the
Conservatives remain on 44% and a hung
parliament on 20% which is down one you
can continue to vote on my Twitter feed
at George Galloway
the pool closes at 9:00 p.m. the first
hours by the good news there's two more
hours just like this still to come stay
tuned to the mother of all talk shows
curious about our curricula have
something to say
then call us now to join the debate on
the mother of all dog shows with George
Galloway this is Dominic Carter a
political reporter in New York for
Verizon FiOS TV news dr. bill Han
agreement progressive Democrats America
PD America tada or black that is still
black so long guns
hello this is Johnson hi this is one
native Roderick author of you'd better
put some ice on that
this is Jamal Thomas from the Fox
hey this is brought him from DC this is
Rachel Blevins a correspondent with RT
America and you're listening to fault
lines with Nixon and Stranahan I'm
waking up in the morning I'm looking for
what Sonny Q for today I tune to fall in
line with Nixon and Stranahan the locust
radio show for your whoa cast am these
guys are the best of the business and
experts when it comes to powerful
they're bringing you the top headlines
with an angle that you won't see in the
mainstream media
all lines are in show on the radio enjoy
immensely talking with Ali and garland
they only treat me from either side with
due respect and it's a wonderful
conversation the best morning news show
in America fault lines with Nixon and
Stranahan lien Garland speak truth to
power from the depth of the swamp itself
right here on radio spot neck
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news a large fire has
swept through a bag factory in the
Indian capital of Delhi killing 43
workers officials say more than 60
people have been rescued and
firefighters had to carry out victims on
their shoulders one by one the blaze
broke out early on Sunday morning
starting on the lower storeys first
before spreading rapidly to the third
floor where at least a hundred workers
were sleeping Prime Minister Narendra
Modi called the fire horrific and sent
his condolences tens of thousands of
protesters have marched through the
streets of Hong Kong in the largest
anti-government rally in months for the
first time since August police allowed a
rally by the pro-democracy group civil
human rights front organizers said that
an estimated 800,000 took part while
police put the number at just over a
hundred and eighty thousand police also
said that 11 people were arrested in
raids ahead of the rally and that a
handgun was seized the protest started
in June over a controversial extradition
bill and have now evolved into broader
anti-government demonstrations in a
statement on Saturday the government
called for calm and said that it had
learned it's lesson and will humbly
listen to and accept criticism and in
the countdown to the British general
election Prime Minister Boris Johnson
has claimed that elite Treasury document
about checks on the northern island
border is wrong Labour leader Jeremy
Corbyn obtained the document claiming
that it proves there will be customs
checks between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland after brexit Johnson
has claimed that the only checks would
be on British exports to the Republic of
Ireland going via Northern Ireland
however this is contradicted not just by
labour but by political and economic
analysts who maintain that because of EU
law products would have to be checked
even if they were not going to the
Republic of Ireland next cold and afraid
a five-year-old child carried her
younger sibling half a martyr safety in
freezing temperatures following a
blackout the five-year-old an 18 month
old arrived at the neighbours home
suffering from injuries relating to cold
weather the five-year-old became scared
when the power went out and carried the
18 month old approximately half a mile
to the neighbours home a 37 year old
woman has been arrested on suspicion of
endangering the wealth
of a child and finally it sold for a
hundred and twenty thousand pounds
that's just over ninety one thousand
pounds last week but the artwork of a
banana duct-taped to a wall has now been
scoffed the performance artist David de
tuna posted videos online showing
himself peeling the fruit from the wall
and consuming it in front of a crowd at
an art exhibition in Miami he described
eating the banana as an art performance
and said that the installation by
Italian artist Merrik so Catalan was
very delicious fortunately for the buyer
the work was apparently solved with a
certificate of authenticity with their
owners allowed to replace the fruit as
and when it is needed that's what Nick
News I'm Jamie Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
The Untold will come to the Open
University of the airwaves with George
Galloway only on Sputnik radio you're
watching or listening or both to the
mother of all talk shows on multiple
platforms every Sunday evening at this
time this is the second hour and there's
another one after this we spent the
first talking largely about the British
general election we're about to switch
our purview to the International issues
of the day and of course to the US
domestic one where President Trump is
facing impeachment but you can still
vote on our poll who will win the
British general election
now the geniuses that brought you the
destruction of Iraq and Afghanistan
repeated their genius in Libya and tried
to do so in Syria but have mercifully
failed though they will not stop trying
in Libya which was the richest country
in Africa there is now virtually no
State at all the doors have been blown
open on to the Mediterranean and much of
Africa is trying at least to head for
the European continent with knock-on
effects in the political systems in
countries like Greece and Italy and
Spain and France and of course even here
in Britain no precious few of those
refugees ever make it to this particular
island the consequences though for the
Libyan people are far more grim Libya
became for a time and I don't think it
has entirely ended a slave market for
black people who were literally being
traded as slaves the country broke into
effectively 3 maybe 23 different
Emirates
warlords and their own militias ruled
the roost there are three parliaments
and there were at least four Prime
Minister's none of those Parliament's
controlled the territory beyond their
own congestion charge area and none of
these Prime Minister's has more than a
modicum of authority across the country
there is war war and war where the
people were promised a peace freedom and
democracy you'll recall that president
Sarkozy and the then Prime Minister
David Cameron proclaimed all of that
from a balcony in Benghazi they wouldn't
be able to restage that stunt because
well no one is safe in Benghazi the
former Libyan Minister for culture and
information became a familiar face and
voice in the British media towards the
end of the rule of Colonel Gaddafi he
was is dr. Moussa Ibrahim and he joins
me on the line now dr. Ibrahim thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
mother of all talk shows it's good to
see you safe I feared for your safety
for some time give us your take on
what's happened to your country this far
in the democratic era assured in by NATO
thank you George
I'm absolutely honored to be with you on
this show thank you I have been
listening to you for more than 20 years
since I was a student in the UK and the
late 90s I have seen you fight the fight
against injustice not just in Britain
which you care for so deeply as I saw
with my own eyes but injustice every
you have been consistent you have been
honest and people can go back to any
previous decade and see that you have
been saying the same things over and
over a very remarkable thing for a
modern era politician that I respect you
I respect you for that and the work you
do is is influential and it helps people
to understand what is going on around
the world my country was a leading
African country with a genuine and
inspirational African and Libyan
liberation project Qaddafi and the
thousands of people who worked with him
and only one of them really planned
funded financially and culturally and
politically a project that aimed to
establish the African Central Bank the
African unified currency the African
unified army the African unified
satellite system and these were not just
dreams they were not just talk but they
were actual projects on on the ground
and Qaddafi was working very hard to
help Africa become independent from the
West
from the global capitalist center which
still enslaved the country as every
single piece of research and study
proves near after year only two years
ago a major study international one came
out that exposed what they call the new
Scramble for Africa in which with
figures and numbers hard economics they
proved that more than 140 billion euros
flow out of Africa to European banks
with
no benefit to the to the continent the
Europeans were extremely worried about
what Libya was leading
they knew that Libya just as any
developing country had internal problems
conflicts some failures even very not
natural for a developing country it had
its tribal structure it had weaknesses
on the political front and they as usual
they had the money the west they had the
experts the intellectuals the
politicians so they mounted a false
revolution a revolution that was very
weak very limited very marginalized most
the vast majority of the Libyan people
refused it they wanted changes to take a
place in the country but they never
wanted to destroy their own country or
ally themselves with the very forces
that kept occupying the country and
destroying it for decades and decades
since the 19th century starting from the
Italians to the French to the British
and the Americans but the global
mainstream media the tools for global
capitalism such as the UN and the
European Union they gave this revolution
the momentum it needed and within a week
I mean how could revolutions just take a
week before you give it a full
international support and air
bombardment by NATO two weeks later and
the reason was very simple and very
straightforward we knew it from the very
beginning they were afraid the West the
capital when I say the west of course I
do not unify I mean the capitalist
center of global imperialism they they
warned us they talked to us in 2008 and
and 9 2010 I was part of some of these
talks and they warned us about what we
were doing in
freaka what happened after that total
destruction of Libya the initiation of
terrorism in the country the building up
of tribal and Islamist militias the loss
of sovereignty of Libya the rod of
national wealth like oil especially
completes Libya complete dependency on
on the west and the UN a story very
similar to Iraq and was going to be
similar to Syria and the results in
Africa are even bigger because all of
the projects of liberation have stopped
and they were replaced george by new
imperialist project so instead of the
african unified army which Qadhafi
supported with hard money now you have
the American African African command and
you have the French g5s military force
and the west of the continent instead of
the African Central Bank which would
have saved billions in African currency
and African wealth you have the complete
control of the French Central Bank and
the London Stock Exchange of the of the
African natural resources and instead of
the African Union developing I'm
becoming more solid more powerful now
the African Union is a weak marginalized
organization that has no rule and the
African continent
because the base country Libya and the
leader who took it upon himself to help
Africa liberate itself were attacked
where black named and their reputation
was attacked in a very vicious way the
results of this throughout what now
eight years prove that everything we
said and everything we try to explain
about what was happening in Libya was
correct
even the British and I'm happy to say
this is something good about British
politics there's a complexity there's a
degree of difference and some color
the British parliamentarian committee
high ranking high level very well-funded
that worked for two years to examine the
British intervention in Libya came out
with one major conclusion that all of
the accusations and justifications for
the attack against Libya in 2011 were
either completely fabricated or at least
greatly exaggerated to mount this war
against my country well that's as
powerful an opening series of shots as
we've ever heard here on the mother of
all talk shows and I'm grateful to you
for it that was truly a tour de force
that will live I think in the ether in
the atmosphere in the internet for a
very long time to come so thank you for
that one of the many powerful points
that you made was the extraordinary
phenomenon of the Western news media
literally cheering on exactly the same
kind of Islamist fanatic head choppers
in Libya that they would be determined
to shoot down dead in the streets here
in our own country we ourselves and I
was just less than one mile away when
the Islamist fanatic Libyan British
citizen facilitated by the British state
rescued by the Royal Navy given succor
and comfort by the British state over
many years he and his small community
the Libyan Islamic fighting group the
blue being in the name I was less than a
mile away
when he blew himself and all those
little children dead apart ripped them
apart in the Manchester Arena so it's
difficult for me not to get angry as I
recall the phenomenon that you described
let me ask you to what extent is Libya's
current division a division that is
tribally based and to what extent is it
based on interpretations of Islamism
other theological ideological divisions
between all these warlords or do they
just wear their Islam on their sleeve to
justify their own warlordism well George
it's a game that the British and
Europeans in general have perfected
since first initiating it in the 19th
century which is basically to come to a
particularly stable context that they
want to rob so what they do they
introduce some sort of a crisis based on
the internal condition of this political
context and of course to do that you
have to study the country you want to
rob and that is why then you come into
the use of intelligentsia and the use of
academic research intellectuals clever
people who will tell you how this
particular context is vulnerable in this
particular way think of India think of
South Africa think of North Africa think
of South America and for Libya they
studied the Libyan context and they
understood that although it's a very
stable very rich very prospering country
but as any nation in the world it has
its internal vulnerability so it has a
tribal system that has worked well
decades and it has the religion of Islam
with its connotations with terrorism and
it has the oil wealth and when you have
a revenue based economy you have some
sort of not very productive or
participatory relationship to the
economy as a citizen but reliance on oil
and this is a weakness there is also the
placement of Libya within the Arab and
African contexts also weak and
vulnerable in other ways so the
Europeans worked on this for years we
were aware of some of this work even
before 2011 and when they came they used
the same Islamist threat the British are
very versed in Islamic terrorism they
initiated it decades even from the 19th
century in the Indian situation and they
knew the leaders of terrorism by name
not just that but it's a very well-known
fact this is not a revelation I'm giving
to your audience when the biggest and
most dangerous Islamist terrorists came
back victorious of course from
Afghanistan very well trained very
well-funded and feeling like with their
spirits high because they defeated the
Soviet Union where did they go that they
come back to Libya or to Saudi Arabia or
to Syria no they went to Manchester they
went to Newcastle they went to London
and they opened up mosques or dominated
they already existing mosques Arab
countries whether they are progressive
countries like Libya Syria Algeria or
reactionary countries like Saudi Arabia
Qatar and they have been demanding that
Britain abandons these terrorists and
give them up but Britain never did
because it knew at that time
it had a powerful weapon that it could
unleash against any government in the
Middle East and they did that indeed
with great success in Iraq they did that
with success to start with buzina
failure in Syria Olivia all of the big
names of Islamic terrorism abdel hakim
al hajj lisa lavie slim al Abadi and we
are led all of these major major figures
with money with training with followers
all of them were based in Manchester
Newcastle Liverpool and other great
British cities so now they are being
used within the tribal framework because
Libya to get things going you have to
get the families and the clans and the
tribes moving with you most of the
tribal social framework is coherent and
patriotic and refuses to collaborate but
as you know George to destroy our
country you only need 2 to 3 percent of
that country collaborating with you if
you have five I mean you had like one
terrorist attacking the public in
Manchester and the horror is too much to
take imagine if there are 10,000 there's
a minute figure but 10,000 terrorists in
a country like Britain they will make
life in passive and this would happen in
Libya they have these thousands of
terrorists collaborating with a small
limited number of tribal clans or
families supported and funded greatly by
France Turkey Britain and Italy
especially more than for example the
states the state is less involved for
its own reasons and then what you what
you want them to do is just to spread
chaos and then what you do you manage
this chaos you manage it so it does not
hit you back or if it does hit you back
it hits you back in a way that you can
bear it that's your system you
powerful capitalist developed system can
take it in and why'd he do that for many
reasons one of them to keep Livia or any
other context weak and unable to become
independent or spread revolution genuine
revolution this time in a bigger context
like the African one and secondly to
plant terror and horror in other
countries and other genuine leaders who
can ever or could ever think about
becoming independent from from from the
West and also to test the ground for new
political systems that would finally
submit to the West the West now is not
sure what government to support in Libya
what faction of society they want to
prolong the crisis so they can rub the
oil for more years so they can sell more
weapons as they do they do that in Saudi
Arabia they do this in Libya secretly of
course in Libya because it's banned by
the UN and there is they test the waters
for what kind of political system what
kind of culture they should finally
support and make victorious so they
guarantee that a lasting heritage of
dependency of subordination takes place
in the country and becomes the heritage
and the culture of that country in a
state of Qaddafi's heritage which is a
heritage of revolution of resistance of
liberation this interview will live long
in the memory as I say certainly in mine
I'm sure I speak for the audience one
final question doctor can Libya survive
all of this can Libya come back our
people like you now in the political
museum or can you again play a part in
change progressive change in your
country
absolutely we are in the heart of every
matter in Libya
I assure you George I know this can be a
little bit hard to see from outside but
the vast majority when and when I say
the vast I mean more than 80 90 percent
of the population are unified against
the Western imperialist project in the
country there are internal divisions and
some differences but for example now the
Libyan army the Libyan Armed Forces they
have gathered most of the tribes in the
country in the east and the south and
most of the tribes in the West the only
pockets that are controlled by the West
are in the capital and two or three
other cities around it and they only
resist the advance of the Libyan armed
forces supported by most Libyan tribes
because of the heavy the heavy funding
and the the arms the advanced arms that
are giving to them by mainly turkey
Italy and France with major diplomatic
supports not weapons but diplomatic and
financial support from the UK we are now
in 2019 stronger we are much more
optimistic our spirits are very high the
culture of liberation the heritage of
the Green Revolution of Libya Qaddafi
the revolution lives on the West they
know that they started a year ago
negotiating with us talking directly to
us I have met many of the leaders of the
European Union and European politicians
face to face and they always say it that
they know that Libya is gonna go back to
the the culture of liberation to the
ideas of Qaddafi they just want to have
some sort of an agreement with us so we
do not go back to our African liberation
project they are extremely gorge
concerned
that if they're rubbing of African
natural resources stops this will be the
biggest crisis that Europe will face for
a long long long time so I assure you
resistance is there and we are winning
the battle we are winning the hearts and
minds of our people and we are advancing
step by step and building up our new
Libya and we will be victorious and we
will come here and talk about it one day
George God willing I could hear a cheer
breaking out across the audience across
the world for that beautiful wonderful
final statement thank you very much
indeed dr. Moussa Ibrahim may God go
with you and protect you let's take a
quick break you're listening to radio
Sputnik
by any means necessary is your guide to
the movement and efforts shaping the
world around us from mass incarceration
no longer am i interested in or
concerned with prison reform I am
interested only in the eradication of
prisons to the battle between police and
water protectors it was a pretty
punishing disregard for the sanctity of
human life but unleashing water cannons
on peaceful prayerful water protectors
from efforts to protect the environment
the climate movement is ready too with
plenty of opposition research and forth
and strength along with you know the
right of both science and morality to
fight them on this - the movement for
black lives when I first saw the Michael
Brown video and I saw that it clearly
contradicted the narrative put forth by
the Ferguson Police Department and by
police supporters in general three words
came to mind color be shocked
stay tuned - by any means necessary five
days a week here on radio Sputnik Radio
Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm George
Galloway and the mother of all talk
shows you join us at the college of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees we are talking 24 hours a day seven
days a week you are listening space
radio Sputnik telling the untold the
mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get for free only on
Sputnik radio I'm sorry I'm running way
behind schedule
I allowed that interview to go on much
longer than scheduled because I thought
it was particularly important and I hope
that you did too which is one way of
saying to my dear friend the wonderful
Elena
now I'm going to have to cut our short
so Elena tell us quickly give us an
overview of the social media feedback
will you
well first of all new countries that we
could add to the list of the listeners
its Greece Portugal Israel kuba and
Norway wonderful
yes so there's been quite a lot of
comments from general elections yeah
people seem to be quite split some
people are saying that if Tories get in
I'm out other people are convinced that
Tories are going to win and I think Cuba
my gosh there might be a number of
British people heading for Cuba if the
tourists get back it's warm it's exact
left-wing people why why not sir but
here this Bella is making quite an
interesting point he's saying you can
only blame labour in this because they
turned their back on brags and and
didn't honor the democratic roads that's
a big issue yeah sorry to say I'm sorry
to say can I cut your shot there maybe
bring you back in later thanks so much
Alan I appreciate that sorry were way
behind schedule an email from Chris
we're in Derry and Ireland says the OPCW
whistle blower story has been covered by
such journalists as max Blumenthal and
Peter Hitchens what do you think about
the deafening silence on the part of the
mainstream media well Chris I think you
know what I think about that Dennis says
father to your comments you might
remember father Jack's Hamill murdered
in his church in France one of his
killers was on a tag of course mrs. may
her predecessors and successors will
continue to fund these lunatics in mrs.
May's case I don't think she had the
ability to know what was happening under
her watch I think Boris does great show
regards Dennis Thank You Dennis
amazing how many selfish people we have
in Britain for tourists to even still
exist never mind
these statistics says a Twitter were the
name too rude for me to read Steve says
I don't trust polls they were almost all
wrong last general election don't get me
wrong never have a mountain to climb but
there are a lot of people Pig sick of
austerity and why vote Tory to get
brexit when Johnson's deal is worse than
Mays and won't get brakes it for years
if at all and Philip says MPs leave or
remain need to be reminded when we vote
they listen and carry out our
instructions like it or not we can never
allow them to decide what they do with
our vote the vote is precious and equal
and must be honored regardless and David
Wilson says this being Twitter most our
labour supporters even if some are
realistic about their chances when
Labour lose they need to look at
themselves for the reasons and not make
ridiculous excuses to do with Russians
buses stupid voters or anything else and
Bobbie 47 says I voted labour all my
life sadly now to confirm my old science
teachers prediction I've now had
rock-bottom and voted Tory Lizzie says
labor and a few independents will win
you including thank you that's the
legend Lizzy we haven't heard from her
for a while we haven't actually had a
woman caller this evening but we are in
the next 20 minutes or so going to have
a very special woman guest but before
Manila Chan the news anchor from RT
America
let me turn as I like to to the on this
day segment those of us of a certain age
remember exactly where we were when John
Lennon was killed it was on this day in
1980 but Mark Chapman shot the former
Beatle four times in the back I remember
very vividly my then wife and I had a
radio alarm clock which came on just in
time for the 7 o'clock news and that of
course was the first item on the news
neither of us said anything to each
other
and both of us openly wept John Lennon's
assassin claimed that he heard voices
telling him to do it after he was
convicted
Chapman claimed to have heard another
voice God's by his apparent religious
conversion did not wash with the parole
panel who have refused to release him
from prison ten times Chapman earlier in
evening had asked John for an autograph
outside the Dakota buildings in New York
where John and Yoko had apartments he
waited for John's return at around 11:00
p.m. and shot him Lennon apparently took
five or six steps into the vestibule of
the apartment block before collapsing it
would have been the birthday today of
another rock star Jim Morrison of the
doors
whose grave I visited in père Lachaise
cemetery in Paris a truly magnificent
Cemetery with all kinds of famous and
interesting people buried there and Jim
Morrison is one of those
he was born on this day in 1943 he was
to die like Jimi Hendrix Janis Joplin
and Kurt Cobain at the age of just 27
rather spooky going back several decades
it was on this day the day after of the
bombing of Pearl Harbor that the United
States entered the second world war in
1941 with both the US and Britain
declaring war on Japan in the area of
bombardment of Pearl Harbor 2,400
Americans were killed and 18 ships were
sunk including 5 battleships later in
the week Germany and Italy declared war
on the United States and it was on this
day in 1983 that television cameras were
allowed into Britain's House of Lords
why one asks did they bother well I was
there of course on that day and if not
on the first day then not long after the
television cameras were allowed in a
group of lesbian protesters swinging
from climbing ropes swung back and forth
across the House of Lords chamber I'm
not making this up
but the rules of the House of Lords
cameras was that they were only allowed
to focus on the members and so the
viewer could see only like a tennis
match the Lord's those of them still
sentient those of them still upright
following from side to side in the House
of Lords these lesbian Vikings that were
swinging across the chamber that no one
else in the country could see look it up
it's all true and finally on this day in
1872 Brigham Young the second leader of
the Mormons after Joseph Smith and the
founder of Salt Lake City married his
stay fifth wife he was he was 71 now
telephone numbers have been asked to
announce them because not enough people
have yet called so it's or two or seven
seven nine eight double to double five
and the US number zero zero one seven
five seven seven four four four four
eight zero you can also tweet me of
course at George Galloway at our tuk
here's a famous place west brom let's
speak to Jason on line one Jason welcome
good evening George how you doing sir by
the grace of God I'm good thank you very
much excellent George um the question
I'd like to put to you is regarding not
only one the general election of this
year obviously which is the main talking
point of everybody within the UK at the
moment and but more specifically the
Labour Party itself there's three gonna
be three possible scenarios on Friday as
we all know it's either going to be a
complete labor whitewash like the polls
which is yes ting or labour might just
think a victory somehow or it's
obviously going to be a hung parliament
and how do you see in the future of the
Labour Party going forward in regards to
all three of those scenarios I would
presume myself if the labour party get
absolutely buttered it would spell the
end of Corbin
the Blair lives would be rejoicing and
it would probably be the end of the
Labour Party like you and I know it from
years and years ago which is an absolute
crying shame but then if the do manage
to sneak a win what then happens and
Corbin obviously cannot then be battered
by his own back benches and his own MPs
and Allen councillors surely then the
Blair watts have got a step down and let
Corbin won the party how he sees fit how
do you sail on a very good call Jason
absolutely the what we used to call the
$64,000 questions when $64,000 was was a
lot more than it is today
let's take those three scenarios
although as Professor Sir John Carter
said there is practically zero chance of
labour winning an overall majority but
if they did win an overall majority
Jeremy Corbyn would be the Prime
Minister unless the Blair writes let
down his tires on his bicycle outside
the house and he can't get to Buckingham
Palace and one of them gets there
instead but all joking apart then Jeremy
Corbyn would be the Prime Minister and
he would have majority to do the things
he said he's going to do but as we I
think both know there's very little
chance of that happening the second
option namely the Tories losing their
majority or rather failing to recover
their majority because of course they
actually already lost it before
dissolving the last Parliament and that
will be a very turbulent period indeed
first of all would these smaller parties
agree to Jeremy Corbyn being the prime
minister of a minority government with
their support the chances of that and my
view are quite slim the Liberals in
particular would be determined to
extract their pound of flesh like they
did in 2010 when Nick Clegg claimed that
he would go into coalition with labour
but only if they got rid of God and
Browne I feel sure that the Liberal
Democrats would play the same role the
Scottish nationalists who may have as we
heard earlier 40 or 41 seats will be in
a position if they want to to extract
big concessions from labour in order for
them to support prop up a minority
labour government one of those could be
the removal law of Jeremy Corbyn but
more likely one of those will be demand
for a new independence referendum
meaning that Britain would have not one
but two new
referendums reruns actually of two
referenda in the next twelve months and
you can imagine not much else will get
done in Britain next year if we have to
rerun a European Union referendum and in
Scotland rerun in Scottish independence
referendum there will be all kinds of
forces moving to try and prevent Jeremy
Corbyn leading such a minority
administration and bringing about those
two referendums it'll be a very rocky
time and we'll be back for a new general
election fairly soon afterwards so those
who are campaigning now don't put away
your campaign boots because you might
have to do all again next year
most likely I think we both know Jason
is that the Tories will have a workable
majority and they will put through the
brexit deal and we will leave the EU at
the end of January at the latest
however as has been made clear elsewhere
in the show that's only the not the
beginning of the end it's only at the
end of the beginning
to paraphrase mr. Churchill because
there will be many many battles over the
terms the deal that we make with the
European Union and there will be many in
the Conservative Party who will try to
make this as much like mrs. Mays Bry no
breaks it in name only as they can
possibly get away with so some of us me
included will be trying to hold Boris
Johnson's feet to the fire to make sure
that the brexit deal he finally does
will be a real brexit Jason don't be a
stranger that was an excellent call now
in role reversal
I am interviewed in normal times five
days a week by one of the brightest and
one of the best anchors in American
television
her name is Manila Chan of arty America
and now I'm going to interview her I
can't tell you what pleasure it is to
see you again Manila
hello Jorge nice to hear from you it's
been a little while yeah I've missed you
I've missed you
no lies I must admit it is a little bit
strange being on this side of the
questions yes but I'll be as nice to you
as you always are for me
no look while I've been away Donald
Trump has sunk deeper and deeper into
trouble hasn't he is this impeachment
prospect real do you think well Jorge
personally I believe that this is Adam
shifts second bite at the Apple
he seemed to have failed after the
Moller report came with a big nothing
burger as they like to call it and I
think this is his second go at trying to
remove Trump from office or at least
give him this political indictment which
we call the impeachment proceedings I
hate that I have to defend President
Trump because I'm personally not a big
fan of his however what's right is white
right and what's wrong is wrong and I
think this is the Democrats second go
because they are trying to rehash the
2016 elections and Hillary Clinton is
all over the media smiling ear-to-ear so
I think it's I think you if you asked a
lot of people at least outside of the
Democratic circles I think a lot of
people would agree with me that this is
a lot to do about nothing and it's just
a media stunt personally I think a lot
of people would agree well it is the
second bite at the Apple isn't it
because they don't seem to know that not
only is Ukraine not in Russia but
Ukraine is probably Russia's biggest
adversary in the near abroad the
relations between Russia and Ukraine are
very poor and yet this is being treated
as Russia gate to
isn't it that's right it absolutely is I
think people still have a hard time
remembering that the Cold War is over
and that the USSR is no longer
especially with all this talk of NATO
and I think a lot of people conflate the
different issues going on between NATO
and the Moller report slash Russia gate
- now it's it should be really if if the
Republicans are listening here they
should really dub this very smug gate if
they really want to brand this for Joe
Biden and and swing the pendulum in the
other direction they really ought to
remind the American viewer that if Joe
Biden were not running for president
would Donald Trump's asked be prohibited
would that be wrong to find out that
there was any American corruption going
on with Ukrainian corruption what is
wrong with that apart from Joe Biden
running for president well I can't
understand why the Democrats can't see
that in any impeachment proceedings the
most likely person to be effectively
impeached is Joe Biden it will kill his
presidential run because his family is
up to the neck in the corruption and the
scandal that is Ukraine gate I agree a
hundred percent but somehow Joe Biden
and his family are getting a pass and
they're getting a pass at this because
the American mainstream media is so
overtly Joe Biden friendly and so
left-leaning that they're willing to
skew the facts and an open look very
glaring obvious truths about what was
happening with hunter Biden because they
want to insulate Joe Biden because he's
the media darling and Trump is not
simple as that
now you mentioned Nieto earlier it was
here of course the circus came to town
there were precious few elephants but
quite a few clowns
and there was a lot of laughter and much
of a Donald Trump's expense and he
seemed to leave in a bit of a half we
call it here in hi Greg hi dodging is
that how it looked from over there I
believe so I think for both since this
is I'm gonna call it a two-party system
because that's really what we have
anybody outside the Democrats that the
Republicans really don't stand any
chance at least not in this political
climate but both parties I think can
agree that the you axe looked bad Donald
Trump made the u.s. look like a clown it
showed that the big players in NATO
Germany France the Queen Anne who was
there or Princess Anne rather who was
there they don't take him seriously
Justin Trudeau's jokes about him nobody
nobody stood up to defend Donald Trump I
think this showed the the lack of
respect that world leaders have for him
and and they just kind of politely smile
along to his face because guess what the
US contributes something like 3.8
billion dollars in the NATO every year
so they smile and not along with him but
behind his back they clearly don't
respect him hmm no you're unable to show
preference but I can I'm a Bernie
Sanders supporter myself how do you see
his chance of winning the Democratic
party's nomination I tell you why I
asked I saw a poll today which shows him
on track to win in Iowa and get off to a
really flying start do you think Bernie
Sanders can beat Joe Biden I think if it
were a fair fight George Bernie could
win if this was a fair election it could
win if the DNC didn't have it in for him
back in 2016 and this is now carried
over now going into 2020
dnc does not want Bernie Sanders to win
he's a disrupter he turns he overturns
the applecart all the time he's done for
doing that in Congress and the DNC
doesn't like him Joe Biden is not a
disrupter Joe Biden is part of the
system and they like that the same way
Hillary Clinton was just next in queue
if you will so Joe Biden is now The
Anointed One
my prediction if you ask me I know you
didn't directly ask but if you ask me my
prediction is that Joe Biden is going to
get the nomination because the DNC has
made him The Anointed One well if you
ask me and you didn't directly but let
me answer the question you didn't ask me
if it's Joe Biden versus Donald Trump I
think Trump wins again but George George
is there anybody that the Democrats have
that can really truly take on Trump yeah
well I think Bernie could I think is the
only one that can beat Trump I think I
think Bernie had the wind beneath his
wings in 2016 and then he was shot out
of the sky by the DNC and Hillary
Clinton unfortunately the I think the
the feeling on the ground here is
Bernie's wings have been clipped since
2016 he has there's a there's a new
democratic party here George the
Democrats have swung granted I get that
that Bernie is is left but the people
here have swung far left into the aoc
wing of the party and even Bernie hasn't
gone that far but he's kind of been
corralled
into that corner I think a lot of people
are now fractioned because of that and
and I don't think he has quite the same
support that he does or he had that he
enjoyed in 2016 among Democrats and
remember none of the polls saw President
Trump happening that was an
impossibility
all the polls back then showed Hillary
Clinton was the projected not only
nominee but the projected winner
so I think a lot of America does not
trust any poll any longer and I don't
think you should trust the polls now I
think when you talk to a lot of a lot of
I would say Gen X and and even older
millennial voters people that are more
or less in my age group a lot of them
are fraction Bernie doesn't have the
same support that he had in 2016 it's
quite unfortunate but I think a lot of
people are looking to find somebody to
bring America back to normalcy if you
will and I think a lot of people view
Joe Biden as that normal place
however the wild card I'll give to Pete
go to judge because he is actually
really gaining a lot of momentum nobody
saw him coming but I still do believe
that the DNC pulls the strings here and
when they pull those strings I think
it's gonna reveal Joe Biden as the
nominee so Bloomberg's billions won't
change the the dynamic at all I don't
think so I think he's a little bit of a
disruption I think he'll make for some
good TV there'll be you know it's the
the Battle of the New York billionaires
but I don't think that is what America
wants or America needs it doesn't matter
if you're a billionaire on the left or a
billionaire on the right what it boils
down to is those two are two New York
billionaires and I don't think America
has the appetite to see two New Yorkers
battle it out Trump is a character
Michael Bloomberg is a nanny state mayor
he wants to control your sodas he wants
to control how often you you go to the
gym and and you know how large a pizza
can be nobody wants that in the US he's
not going to get enough support in the
middle of the country
that is where you win elections Michael
Bloomberg with his billions of dollars
paying for his billions in television
and radio and internet commercials I
don't think he's gonna be able to swing
the middle of this country the way
President Trump did unfortunately Manila
I can't tell you what a delay is to
talk to you again I look forward to
seeing you again soon and the very nice
manila presentation this coming week
George how exciting I hope so
God willing we'll all be back together
again soon Manila Chan presenter of in
question on Rt America on which in
ordinary times I'm a regular daily guest
thank you very much indeed for joining
us it's time for the news with Jamie
Lowe curious about our curricula have
something to say then call us now to
join the debate on the mother of all
shows with George Galloway
[Music]
hi this is Juanita Broderick you'd
better put some ice on that
[Music]
hey this is Brian from DC this is Rachel
Blevins a correspondent with RT America
and you're listening to spot lines with
Nixon and Stranahan
when I'm waking up in the morning I'm
looking for what's on the queue for
today I tuned the fault line with Nixon
and Stranahan the locust radio show for
your whoa cast and these guys are the
best in the business and experts when it
comes to policy they're bringing you the
top headlines with an angle that you
won't see in the mainstream media all
lines of British show on the radio enjoy
immensely talking with ally and garland
to feel you should treat me from either
side with due respect and it's a
wonderful conversation the best morning
news show in America fault lines with
Nixon and Stranahan lien Garland speak
truth to power from the depths of the
swamp itself right here on radio spot
neck
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news a large fire has
swept through a bag factory in the
Indian capital of Delhi killing 43
workers officials say more than 60
people have been rescued and
firefighters had to carry out victims on
their shoulders one by one the blaze
broke out early on Sunday morning
starting on the lower storeys first
before spreading rapidly to the third
floor where at least a hundred workers
were sleeping Prime Minister Narendra
Modi called the fire horrific and sent
his condolences tens of thousands of
protesters have marched through the
streets of Hong Kong in the largest
anti-government rally in months for the
first time since August police allowed a
rally by the pro-democracy group civil
human rights front organizers said that
an estimated 800,000 took part while
police put the number at just over a
hundred and eighty thousand police also
said that 11 people were arrested in
raids ahead of the rally and that a
handgun was seized the protest started
in June over a controversial extradition
bill and have now evolved into broader
anti-government demonstrations in a
statement on Saturday the government
called for calm and said that it had
learned it's lesson and will humbly
listen to and accept criticism and in
the countdown to the British general
election Prime Minister Boris Johnson
has claimed that a leaked Treasury
document about checks on the northern
island border is wrong Labour leader
Jeremy Corbyn obtained the document
claiming that it proves there will be
customs checks between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland after brexit Johnson
has claimed that the only checks would
be on British exports for the Republic
of Ireland going via Northern Ireland
however this is contradicted not just by
labour but by political and economic
analysts who maintain that because of EU
law products would have to be checked
even if they were not going to the
Republic of Ireland next cold and afraid
a five-year-old child carried her
younger sibling half a martyr safety in
freezing temperatures following a
blackout the five-year-old an 18 month
old arrived at the neighbor's home
suffering from injuries relating to cold
weather the five year old became scared
when the power went out and carried the
18 month-old approximately half a mile
to the neighbours home a 37 year old
woman has been arrested on suspicion of
endangering the well
of a child and finally it sold for a
hundred and twenty thousand pounds
that's just over ninety one thousand
pounds last week but the artwork of a
banana duct-taped to a wall has now been
scoffed the performance artist David de
tuna posted videos online showing
himself peeling the fruit from the wall
and consuming it in front of a crowd at
an art exhibition in Miami
he described eating the banana as an art
performance and said that the
installation by Italian artist Mariko
Catalan was very delicious fortunately
for the buyer the work was apparently
solved with a certificate of
authenticity with their owners allowed
to replace the fruit as and when it is
needed that Sputnik news I'm Jaime Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold
[Music]
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio that simply must be a
publicity stunt the banana for a hundred
and twenty five though
apart from anything else had them what
happens when the banana rots well they
have to spend two hundred and twenty buy
again wait they could just go down go
down to the Aldi or the Asda or the
little and get it for a less than a
pound you are well less now I'm joined
as you can see by Adam Gary hashtag ask
Adam people already asking in their
droves let me run through some of them
with regards to the United Nations
climate conference in Spain cop 25 I
wonder if you can make Adam address the
issue of carbon quota or carbon credit
as the cleverest man in England he
should be the right man to talk about
this with authority because it doesn't
make much sense at least not to me not
me actually I don't think it's supposed
to make sense this is from syndra hip
saw in Norway hope you can make Adam
address this let me make you go on oh I
feel the force of nature coming down
upon me like hopefully some on certain
green benches will in a week not that I
going to mention that well in general
whenever someone hears the word quotas
run as far as you can in the other
direction this is true whether it's
trade quotas which fit under this
surreptitious thing they call non-tariff
trade barriers which is a tariff through
the back door or a stealth tariff to use
language borrowed from the nemec's of
Gordon Brown
I don't like quotas when you have
all-women shortlists or men with one or
long lists or dwarf shortlist I think
that a position should be gained because
of merit in the business world and in
general with maybe the exception of the
clerical world and the House of Lords
before tony blair stuffed booze
merchants and his
flatmates and other people in that once
great legal and legislative chamber now
as for this carbon quota stuff it's a
lot of rubbish and I'm actually going to
say something nice about mr. Corbyn
which people probably weren't expecting
but of course this is Piers corbin the
brother of the leader of the Labour
Party he makes a point and he's a
scientist that carbon he calls it the
gas of life I believe he calls it
because it's good for the trees they
with through the photosynthetic process
they absorb it and it's food carbon is
plant food and so the idea that we need
that we need to limit carbon is itself a
fallacy and another point that my
favourite mr. Corbyn makes is that an
increase of carbon in the atmosphere
isn't the cause of changing temperatures
but it's the result of naturally
occurring temperature changes so the
idea that one can artificially enforce a
quota of how much a natural substance is
protruded and exhausted into the
atmosphere is simply ludicrous these
people are attempting to play God and
when those have given up on faith and
think that they're gods on earth they
quite frequently start to typecast
themselves in that way there you go
syndra you thought you might have
stumped them but you didn't
Andy Omega asks what's your verdict on
Farraj modifying the brexit party to the
reform party will it carry momentum and
political influence well I'd been
vindicated I said that Faraj is
something of an 18th century liberal and
now he's sort of transitioning as
everyone does these days into a sort of
gladstone Ian figure now Faraj and
Gladstone have some similarities they
both started out life in the Tory party
though everyone tends to forget that
because they were much more famous
outside of the Tories than in and the
other thing that similar is they both
went to the radical liberal mind you not
the socialists but the radical liberal
left the older they got always believing
in free-market economics and
so these are some interesting parallels
between the two of them so frankly if a
Gladstone Ian's party led by Faraj were
to replace the Joe Swinson party which
is neither Lloyd George ask we Thor glad
Stanley neither liberal nor democratic
quite it's a bit like the Holy Roman
Empire of parties and I think it may
suffer a similar fate at the ballot box
but yeah I mean I'm quite the opposite
of a Gladstone II and liberal but if it
does what it says on the tin and if he
can admit that it's a Gladstone II and
Liberal Party sure why not go and
replace the Liberal Democrats you'll
have as much if not slightly more
success I should say Adam has absolutely
no idea that of the questions that I'm
posing to him here's another one evening
gentlemen went with the general election
night thus likely a Labour defeat - do
you believe it's the end of the road for
Project Corbin
if so who do you envisage wrestling
control of the Labour Party long term I
think it's going to be less of a
wrestling match than sort of someone
crawling out of the desert on all hands
and knees only to be told that the water
fountain has run dry possibly because of
too little carbon in the atmosphere I
think that there is going to be assuming
that Johnson's Tories win which is a
fair assumption as John was saying
earlier I agree with much of that I
think that there's going to be a segment
in the labour true believers that will
want Corbin to continue and there'll be
there'll be a minority numerically but
there'll be very vociferous in their
chants and in the expressions of why
Corbin should stay on ultimately though
I don't think he will John MacDonald
who's already planning to be sort of a
Nostradamus of the New Labour Party
combined with the kind of Cardinal
Richelieu he's already said that he
wants a woman leader which is a quota of
course of sorts of big sorts and so that
sort of narrows it down it means that
McDowell
is ruling himself out but he's certainly
going to be the power behind the throne
I think he's probably too nasty of a
character far from being the magic
grandpa is the supporters of Corbin call
him MacDonald is sort of like a nasty
he's sort of like the Tin Man from The
Wizard of Oz you've got wicked witches
of the North London which is Emily
Thornberry you could do a whole panto
but he can't be the leader so what it's
going to be a woman and just just to
make things ever more horrifying we were
supposed to break sit on Halloween that
didn't work but to keep that spirit up
some say and I don't think she'll get
through that just Phillips the woman
with the endless mouth might yes Philips
will definitely be a candidate yes I
mean the softly on the ballot the
Socrates impersonation festival of
central Birmingham wouldn't be the same
if she had to resign her road to lead
the Labour Party but I don't think
she'll get in even though she has the
only qualification that John McDonnell
cares for being born without male
genitalia
Liam Ryan says ask Adam how's your
infatuated support for imperialist porn
Duterte holding out for for being an
imperialist porn he's probably the most
sovereignty minded an anti-imperialist
president that the Philippines has ever
had in its modern history I would
actually compare him to yo say Larissa
one of the national sort of founding
fathers of the original anti-colonial
struggle in the Philippines so there's
really no answer to the question since
it's a preposterous
presumption Duterte is hated precisely
because he pursues a neutral foreign
policy that places prosperity for his
people who were former impoverished and
they should be over entangling
alignments alignments now our poll
number two of the evening
who would Boris Johnson fear most in a
face to face a Andrew Neil be George
Galloway see Duncan Ferguson
it's just Winston autonomy it would be
for me who
be Duncan Ferguson I think anyone would
fear to face him well some I don't know
what kind of voice just came to me there
but somebody in here doesn't know who
Duncan Ferguson is the whole gallery
doesn't know who Duncan Ferguson is
Duncan Ferguson is one of the most
magnificent athletes footballers ever to
play on this island
he went from my hometown of Dundee
United to Glasgow Rangers hard luck lads
in the Cup final today and then he went
south to Everton and became a club
legend and now he's the interim manager
and they beat Chelsea 3-1 on Saturday an
occasion marked by big Duncan as he's
known picking up the ball boys and
literally twirling them round his head
his house was burgled by two idiots who
imagined that they could take on Duncan
Ferguson and he hospitalized both of
them well done and then another two
idiots tried to do exactly the same
thing and he hospitalized both of those
Dudley well he has four convictions for
punching people he's a man of conviction
so that's not Duncan we need Vixen
politicians any way you can vote on my
Twitter Andrew Neil George Galloway
or Duncan Ferguson let's take a call
from Austria Yvonne in Austria welcome
Yvonne hello George how are you it's an
honor to speak to thank you very much
for taking the call thank you thank you
very much we don't get many calls from
Austria thank you no follow you all the
way from Austria since your beautiful
features like very much prison actually
for Julian I meant before that but yeah
that was really amazing experience but
thank you I have to say I was bit I
liked it you know you talk about the
mana conviction that's you I think and
then talk about Tony Bennett I actually
managed to see
speaking he was the greatest of them all
yeah so I have a bit of a stalker so to
speak so I follow you around very
welcome I watched you on Friday night
west bromwich East working men's club
yeah we have a really good audience
actually I guess the biggest meeting
we've had was absolutely packed and
people can still see on YouTube yeah
it's really lovely
yeah I mean it got there's a lot of
things like that's a chapter for ages
but anyway there wasn't meaning that
that cause my ears at the end of hosting
several state yeah yeah hustings the
opponent the opponents didn't turn up
we're not going to talk about the actual
contest yes do you think I wanted to ask
you was at the very end you said
something about announcing on Saturday
that you were going to form a political
party yes yes well let me tell you that
we did found the Workers Party or
Britain on Saturday afternoon in the
Kendrick building in West Bromwich in
the West Midlands and I think when you
see the pictures and the video next
weekend right after the election you'll
be very pleased indeed by the quality
the quantity and the surroundings for
that matter for the party so it was
formed on Saturday and it will be
launched it will go live as it were this
coming Saturday Workers Party of Britain
you can look at it as a kind of breaks
it Labour Party a socialist party that
believes in brexit and will be trying to
build support amongst those sections of
the British working class that have
fallen out of love with the Labour Party
lost what do you have on oh well I'm
just you know I'm always scared
in my eyes somehow listening to you and
it's kind of I mean I do think somebody
wants to treat you that I've been
treated that is the American who's like
it's in charge of America it's not only
important for America it's important for
the whole world and that's another
reason why I follow politics very
closely and they're hearing that you're
gonna do that I think that's what
Britain needs really it needs a new
party leader I mean I mean the world
needs honesty god bless you everyone
what you're doing in Austria
incidentally you're working that well
I'm a king I work with children yes I do
and you're from me you're from from the
Emerald Isle I can detect wonderful a
lovely Dublin accent thank you very much
for all your kind words and thoughts
let's go to Roy in Brentwood go ahead
Roy very much your honesty and integrity
are for 50 years
thank you I just I just asked your large
ask this question when I refurnished at
banks in 2002 I after the subprime 455
million billions or what have been
better to refinance the public services
and put the money into the economy
rather than give it to the banks who
paid their self bonuses officers so
their incompetence we would have
actually been better taking all those
hundreds or billions into a helicopter
and scattering them randomly across the
land because at least then that money
would have been spent would have
circulated kick-started and circulated
in the economy rather than disappearing
into the black hole of the commercial
bank vaults thus falling foul of all
moral hazard of rewarding failure in
private enterprise
with some subvention from public funds
the very opposite atom of what
capitalism supposed to stand for well
quite right it's not capitalism at all
it's a kind of it's it's it's a banker's
socialism and and it's appalling as
someone who's a libertarian free-market
here with a few exceptions I'm not a
doctrinaire in any field but I'm
generally an economic libertarian it was
absolutely perverse what happened when
the shop round the corner folds you
don't get a government subsidized
bailout when someone defaults on their
debt they don't get as government
subsidized bailouts so why should these
banks which operate it under the worst
practices took a system that was already
appalling called fractional reserve
banking and they just multiplied it to
such grotesque levels of sub economic
vulgarity if anyone deserved to fall and
fall badly it was these people it's the
Jimmy Cliff theory of capitalism the
bigger they are the harder they fall but
not when you have this bankers
socialists well they were too big to
fail bankers too big to jail well Jimmy
could the Jimmy Cliff theory of
economics which is a pure free market
model would disagree with that but
Gordon Brown who then went in
preposterous he said that he saved the
world felt otherwise Manoli and a former
Trotsky Alastair darling
quite right my first encounter that
Waverly station pressing Trotskyite
track Tron bewildered real women well
it's not that much of a stretch because
Trotskyites are in love with power
they hate individual freedom they hate
working cause people speaking for
themselves they hate tradition they hate
just about everything I've liked but
they they like the idea of control and
what better control then to fuse a
supposedly thriving banking industry
with the government it's Trotskyism wit
to borrow a phrase from Vince Cable with
a pinstripe veneer well last what do you
ride you know while I agree entirely
with you the fact is they blame the
Tories for this but the fact remains it
was Gordon Brown that basic lend this
money to the bankers for their
incompetence you
he didn't laid unless he gave it gratis
he just gave it and not and they didn't
even take seats on the board I recall
vividly alistair darling seeing in the
house then I've never been a believer in
the government having a chair at the
boardroom table of private banks and I
rose to say oh yes you were I first met
you
pressing trot Skytrax on the world of
real women in Waverly station Roy thanks
very much for that let's take a quick
break radio Sputnik we speak your
language
find us at Sputnik news calm
tune in every Thursday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker for the regular
segment called veterans for peace where
we focus on the contemporary issues of
war and peace that affect veterans their
families the country and the world as a
whole
veterans for peace president Gerry
Condon joins the show every Thursday
hear about this and more every Thursday
right here on radio Sputnik we are above
all the latest developments and we don't
take any sides Radio Sputnik telling the
untold
the mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway the world is our classroom and
you're welcome to sit in and join the
seminar who would Boris Johnson fear
most in a face-to-face a Andrew Neil B
George Galloway C Duncan Ferguson you
can vote on my Twitter feed art speak
central says Libya today is a broken
country do to America and it's grubby
allies and Jonathan hands says the
Western imperialist forces were
determined to destroy Libya and Janka
says Gaddafi was loved across Africa his
death setback the continent but at least
it has achieved one thing waking up a
sleeping mass to the cold reality that
crooks intend to rape the land
here's one from Angela and Newport what
do you think's happened to the man and
the double breasted pajamas namely Jake
Jacob Riis mogs he's obviously gone into
hiding
yeah well he's campaigning in his
constituency and posting some rather
amusing things on Twitter but all we of
a very innocuous and anodyne nature but
essentially some of the stage managers
of the Tory Party that haven't yet been
shown the exits that came in during that
GaAs the era of Cameron they haven't
they're trying to stage manage this
campaign which is one of the worst
campaigns there's ever been it's only
saving graces the Weber campaign has
been even worse which is to say nothing
of the Lib Dem campaign which is like
watching a bus go over a cliff backwards
only to see that the Seas being drained
because of global warming with George
Swinton on the side of the bus with zero
with mouth wide open like a shark ready
to attack yeah they've Vettori
hi come on you know the the boring men
in grey suit said Torrey HQ have kept
him out of the limelight because of a
frankly misunderstood statement that he
made about the Granville tragedy on on
another radio show and I think it's
rather
because he's one of the most articulate
and more amusing figures they've got and
by God could they could use a dose of
interesting and articulate in this
campaign I think he's out a favor
if the Tories get back will he be
dropped or is he just being parked for
the duration I think he's just being
parked for the duration because his
position on the front bench is one that
isn't so much concerned with policy or
interacting with the public he's
believer at the House of Commons so this
is about constitutional law and theory
it's about procedural issues it's not
it's about as far from a populistic kind
of position as one could get
so if there's anywhere that these sort
of sweaty men in grey suits would feel
comfortable with him being it would be
in that position let's hear from Ian in
Hounslow
in London Ian go ahead hello George nice
seeing you again
yes it's good to speak I just want to
pick up about brexit and the remain as
virtue signalling and final brick cities
are these sort of products
knuckle-dragging white racists now there
is a stream on YouTube called Navarro
media and the young chap called David
Waring
blaming breaks it and breaks it ears for
the news being preoccupied with Briggs
ik to the exclusion of all other matters
including the tragedy of Yemen now you
pointed out the disgraceful behavior the
nearly 90 MPs on labor who are absent on
the early day motion to put forward an
arms embargo on Saudi Arabia over Yemen
now those 80 odd 90 MPs two-thirds of
them are remain as and a third of them
are labor Friends of Israel almost all
of them voted for the war d-roc and
almost all of them voted against the
investigation of the war in Iraq I've
contacted David via YouTube and he
hasn't had the decency to reply well I
have nothing to do with Novara media
which seems to me to typify precisely
the culture war
issues that I was talking about earlier
in the evening so I'm not able to guide
you on how to get any redress from them
but the news is worse than you think
it wasn't eighty or ninety it was well
over 100 Labour MPs and it wasn't an LED
motion which is a meaningless
declaration on a piece of paper it was
an attempt to legislate on the floor of
the house introduced by Jeremy Corbyn to
suspend all British arms exports to
Saudi Arabia until an investigation had
taken place as to their illegal use in
the slaughter of civilians in Yemen
it was a three-line whip and more than
well over 100 Labour MPs voted against
it or abstained broke the three-line
whip that mr corbyn had maintained now I
argued then directly to him that this
was the moment to go for the Blair
rights to take the whip away from them
to suspend them to make it impossible
for them to be Labour MPs again because
what could be better territory for a
Jeremy Corbyn figure than a group of MPs
actively supporting the most reactionary
vicious vile head-chopping
crucifying torturing obscurantist
regime on the earth namely Saudi Arabia
I would love to fight enemies on that
terrain we had gay Labour MPs lining up
with Saudi Arabia will they throw gay
people at the top of buildings we had
women Labour MPs standing up for Saudi
Arabia despite the imprisonment from
dawn to dusk from daughter hood to adult
and motherhood of women citizens of
Saudi Arabia being effectively
incarcerated in their own homes in their
own families and to their male relatives
what better territory would there have
been for Jeremy Corbyn to confront and
defeat the Blair rights than that if he
had done so then more than a hundred of
these Blair rights would not now be
running as Labour MPs in the current
general election just think about that
thanks Ian let's hear from Adrian in
Clapham go ahead Adrian hi-gloss the
leader sorry could you say now another
goin near goodness the aramean
easy buddy literally children screaming
its election week I want to know in
particular what constituencies in the
country do you believe more specifically
that label wouldn't grasp it because
here in South London everywhere every
quiet you know they're quite often
mystical video service before it isn't
London people London Labour will do very
well in London very well especially
under fire but I know for England that
was University out of London so no it's
quite different and them mentality quite
different comparator yeah yeah so what
you could you recognize well I don't
want to name the constituencies that
would be invidious because no one's here
to answer me and argue the point
yeah I'm going to give you their areas
I'm going to give you the areas right
across the West Midlands
the East East Midlands the North West
the north east north east Wales and
South Wales
labour will lose seats going down like
dominoes that's my prediction
but then the pressure party they'd lost
for the full conservative conservative
and districts for MPS on contract
please no members of the European
Parliament who were elected as brexit
Party MEP s but I'm not resigning their
seats now that they've left the brexit
party which seems no I don't think I'll
make any difference I don't I'm sorry to
tell you it's not it won't be the breaks
a party that is taking these seats from
Labour it will be the Conservatives see
if I'm see if I'm right and see if I'm
wrong come back next week thanks for
that Adrienne Jennifer in pleaser oh go
ahead Jennifer I don't want your life
Gayatri to take this the wrong way but
me and my friend adore you thank you
very much also be watching you in West
Brom listening to what we've been saying
and I know that you mentioned about your
new party France a marvelous idea
it reminded me many years ago when
Arthur Scargill yeah had formed the
socialist Labor Party and of course you
remember this very well it was really in
in after the aftermath of the dreadful -
strike and so he blaring all the damage
that had been done to the labor movement
but actually I remember I'd actually
joined the socialist Labor Party then
the very early stages but it never
really got off the ground George and so
I wondered what he thought of this now
it's a very good question Jennifer the
lateness of the hour doesn't allow me to
do it justice entirely I would say in
short that author author's idea was at a
time that hadn't come it was premature
it was exactly at the rise of new labor
and the leadership of Tony Blair which
captivated large sections of the party's
membership and for a time large sections
of the electorate the writing was on the
wall but the working class couldn't see
it yet after now 25 years or more I
think that the writing is still there
and more and more people can see it that
the Labour Party is now whatever you
think of it now is about to move
decisively to the right that's the only
way it can react to an anticipated
defeat of Jeremy Corbyn and moreover
that's the only way it will react they
will not elect and did anyone to the
left of Jeremy Corbyn couldn't even get
on the ballot paper to be a candidate to
be the leader of the Labour Party so the
spread of leadership candidates will be
from roughly speaking Angela Reina to
Kirsten and Emily Thornbury it will be
someone on that spectrum that will be
the leader then they'll start to blame
Corbin for his international positions
his opposition to war and nuclear
weapons and so on and in other words
Corbin will be scapegoated for any
defeat that occurs on Thursday so the
Labour Party will be moving right and
will be moving in an increasingly anti
brexit direction
so we intend to stand on socialist
politics and embracing brexit and its
opportunities that affords us jennifer
forgive me I can't come back to you for
more than a minute but please give me
your last word wonderful George I wish
you every luck I truly hope that the be
successful and this is very stoical time
for Arthur Scargill just matter it was a
matter of timing no author kept the name
labor he's the only person in the
country other than labor that's allowed
to use it but I'm sorry to tell you
that's not the asset that it once was
how's the pool doing Andrew Neil 35%
down one George Galloway 45% up one
Duncan Ferguson a wise 20% of you now
you can still vote until 10 o'clock on
my Twitter feed on that Gigi Woods if
Jeremy Corbyn was in complete control of
the Labour Party's direction acting out
his views on the EU that he had for
decades when he sat next to George
standing for the working class along
with socialist policies would you
support him or still back Boris hashtag
ask Adams one for you Adam whoever won I
would back whoever had the harder brexit
and a possibility of winning and in 2017
even though I disagreed with Corbin's
economic policies I disagreed with the
way in which he phrased a lot of his
foreign policies I'm anti-war but for
very different reasons I will go into
the other modes with disagreements but
it kind of sort of seemed in 2017 that
may who is a dyed-in-the-wool
manor was perhaps not as much of a
conviction brag satirist Corbin it sort
of seemed in 2017 as though Corbin could
have broken out of the box and said
voila
happy birthday sorry about the lack of
clothes by the way I'm a brexit here and
there's nothing of the thorn breeze and
the rest of them could do about it
that Jeremy Corbyn who was also weirdly
the one who performed in front of young
and misguided Romaniacs at rock
festivals and who took great applause
that Colvin is no more and the Corbin
that for decades spoke out quite
correctly about how bad the EU was that
Corbin is also no more so in a brexit
election I favor whoever wants the
hardest brexit who can actually win
which discounts some of the smaller
parties I have to say Robert Hickey says
Gaddafi was ok a bit strange but better
than a lot of them I think that sums up
Gaddafi quite well don't you it's it's
it's neither the most generous nor is it
the most critical view so I'll go with
that as Tony says once Colonel Gaddafi
decided to move away from the US dollar
the Americans had to remove him I went
to gold he was I certainly do
I certainly do but luckily I haven't yet
been massacred or killed over it the way
he was the masses says can our country
ever be described as free or democratic
when it is in enforced debt to the IMF
well I don't think the debt of any kind
is compatible with any sort of freedom
because once the government gets into
debt you're essentially living in a
slave economy which will quickly become
violent let it not be said that the
second world war was caused by anything
other than a German economic policy
which was not so different than what the
Federal Reserve and other central banks
are doing by printing money and issuing
bonds that can't realistically be
redeemed other than through the issuing
of more bonds and more printed money in
Germany they called them
faux bills which were essentially it was
a promissory note that was given where
they were they sold the me faux bills to
get the cash that they needed for all
the maddening deficit spending but they
knew they couldn't ever pay this back
and so what did they do they invaded
countries that had a gold ster that had
stocks of gold and because they needed
money they had given away these fake
notes printing fake monopoly money and
they needed to invade then they had a
deal with the Soviet Union where for the
raw materials that the Soviet Union had
an abundance they'd get the finished
goods that the Germans made at a very
high level and when that went awry they
invaded the Soviet Union which had very
valuable commodities like gold like oil
like rubber like copper like timber and
so if the Second World War could be
caused by debt the third world war will
almost certainly be caused by debt Wow
powerful stuff let's take our quick and
our final break of the evening
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
June in every Thursday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker for the regular
segment called veterans for peace where
we focus on the contemporary issues of
war and peace that affect veterans their
families the country and the world as a
whole
veterans for peace president Gerry
Condon joins the show every Thursday
hear about this and more every Thursday
right here on radio Sputnik we are above
all the latest developments and we don't
take any sides Radio Sputnik telling the
untold
the mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway the world is our classroom and
you're welcome to sit in and join the
seminar let's get through as many calls
as we can in the time remaining Kenny in
for Kirk is on the line
Kenny welcome a lot y'all traitor I'm
good especially after the cup final
today but you'll know what they ask you
what why don't you give up here and and
sir destroy Parliament I thought you
liked me Kenny would you would you me
Parliament
destroying the class fathers arguments
I'm in East Cobb right
in January the East Cobb right village
theater come down you're not that far
away and see me there and our new party
may well stand in the Scottish
Parliament elections but not me because
I'd be I'd be a fish out of water in
that in that we Parliament I must tell
you if you love you love me if you love
me don't force me the 2ds me will
succeed we are senators daily majority
the SNP me achieve forty but that would
be enough for sovereignty decree on
Monday
well if she goes for another referendum
are be in Scotland for the duration to
fight as I for in 2016 or 2013 rather
just some affair to some effect I'll be
just saying no all over again all over
Scotland
2015 let me give ended thanks thanks now
tell me how do you see the Scottish end
of this general election going I think I
think the same people will increase
spark over the roads backyard I think
like what's gone I think Jerry
I think getting's gone interesting gone
to the Taurus the Tories are rising
they're in second place and rising
Labor's in third place and falling yes
sir the union's body will increase
particularly where breaks it breaks
apart over to where we shall see indeed
Kenny thanks very much for the call my
friend
see you on East Cobb right on I think
it's the 18th of January if someone can
just check that date for me Ross is in
Liverpool Ross welcome to the show all
right
I'm doing fine sirs the football and
Liverpool both of you well done boy I
was wondering what you thought so
thought on Isis behind eternal to UK you
mean these Isis prisoners being held in
Syria well I think they should be handed
to the legitimate government of Syria
and they should be executed by firing
squad for having invading invaded Syria
and caused the deaths of literally
hundreds of thousands of people many of
whom met their end in the most sickening
revolting inhuman way that it's possible
for anyone to lose their life so the
last thing I want is these people coming
back here getting legal aid your expense
and my expense to put up a fancy defense
and then be held in prison only to be
released halfway through and end up on
London Bridge
muttering somebody else what do you
think and I don't really agree with that
I don't think it's very humane and I
know that these people are probably
being brainwashed but ultimately if we
just execute them she all that she's
taking us down to a level that we
shouldn't be well of course I hear the
argument and here the brainwashed
argument but my main concern is this
that these people cut no more throats
decapitate no more people kill no more
innocents no more priests no more
bishops no more clerics destroy no more
of the great heritage either of Syria or
here in our own country I'm not prepared
to take the risk for the sake of of
liberalism we're just going to have to
agree to differ on that Ross because I
need a press on to Dave in Warsaw go
ahead Dave hey George how are you I'm
good not Zia from your gone yes all
right before I get into my main call
which is impeachment I just wanted to
clarify your guests are before Manila
about Bernie Sanders and his support
yeah Manila seemed to think that Bernie
was something of a short bolt or a
busted flush yeah he just passed four
million donations within the last couple
weeks and AOC actually endorsed him
along with it was Manila's point that
that's bad news not good news though AOC
and our elk identity politicians are
precisely what Bernie doesn't need well
was that this whole impeachment thing is
a distraction the reason why I say that
is while the Democrats are doing their
dog and pony show the things that you
don't hear about is that the Democrats
actually in the house just passed the
Patriot Act they extended it and not
only that overdoses and suicides
overtook car overtook car accidents as
the leading cause of death Trump is now
cutting 700 people from food stamps and
thinking about moving 14 thousand more
troops back into the Middle East he's
denied now of course thank you he's
denied it sure but
these are the things that we've you know
you don't care about oh I hear about the
ball Dave points very well mate
thank you very much indeed I hope you're
right about Bernie Sanders but we've got
to clear the decks cause there's a
legend on the line Norma in Bristol
Norma welcome hello George I'm trying to
look on the bright side because some of
them may be the results of the election
okay three comments actually the Moussa
Ibrahim is a brought him about Libya I
thought no it was amazing I thought he
was fantastic I mean yes you two made
him the president well it was
complicated but it opened my ice is
something quite refreshing to people
well not refreshing but you know
something new and went away from British
politics yeah I don't know anything I
think I'm right Nelson Mandela died on
the 6th of December six years ago I
think it was the sick yeah yeah but you
know I should have mentioned them I'll
scald the gentleman who should know
better who drew up the important dates
I'll scold him when we're finished
there's an organisation could make votes
matter and it's them about PR yeah and
to be honest if there's another election
within the next 12 months or whatever it
is a fairer system I think really
because you've instead of the
constituencies winning your actual votes
in the way they I don't know quite how
they work it out but it would be fairer
really don't you think I do I've always
supported proportional representation
but just as the UN Security Council will
never be reformed because the existing
members of it would have to vote for
that reform so this Parliament will
never introduce proportional
representation all of these
and very exceptional circumstances
because they are all the beneficiaries
of the current system and turkeys don't
normally vote for an early Christmas so
I wouldn't hold your breath for that
happening but if the hung parliament
that at least a quarter maybe more of
you are hoping for half of you maybe
hoping for if that comes to pass we will
be into another general election next
year I'm absolutely sure about that
aren't you Adam if there's a hung
parliament and yes and this is what's
quite interesting the Conservatives and
I believe labour also are committed to
repealing this ghostly Cameron Clegg
fixed term Parliament's act witches were
along with four pieces of legislation
that Tony Blair polls probably no time
to name them is one of the most wretched
pieces of constitutional vandalism of
the last 30 years I think that if there
is a hung parliament an election is
inevitable I think the only thing that
such a hung parliament could virtually
unanimously agree on is repealing this
fixed term Parliament's act but whether
such a hung parliament could could be
able to foster a majority behind some
referendum to steal breaks in a remain
versus remain referendum which is what
the Labour Party want that could end up
in so much infighting that there could
even be an election before that I think
that no one in their right mind should
hope for a hung parliament someone you
know whether they're on the left or on
the right people should just pray that
one party wins the solid majority even
if its majority of one because a hung
parliament would really thrust the
country into a crisis that would make
the last three years of like child's
play what do you think Norma I think
it's a matter really but it might well
be a hung parliament but these make
votes matter people they've been
emailing me and they're doing a damn
good job you know for sure I mean for me
I personally argued face-to-face just me
and
with both Gordon Brown and Tony Blair
before him that now that you have these
big parliamentary majorities you must
legislate now for proportional
representation and then the Tories will
never be back because even mrs. Thatcher
never got more than 42 percent of the
popular vote but 42 percent of the
popular vote under our electoral system
can well give you a landslide
parliamentary majority but neither of
them did so and now we have the very
real prospect of the Conservatives going
back now when you think about this non
it is actually a damning indictment on
the Labour Party and on the mass media
that has facilitated it the party that's
been in power for a decade most of which
has been a decade of withering bitter
austerity which has been led by a series
of donkey's David Cameron Theresa May
and now Boris Johnson is seriously going
to get another majority on Thursday if
the polls are right it is a damning
indictment on everyone concerned in the
political class the political system the
Labour Party the tea you see the BBC I
could I could go on everyone who is
contributed to the fact that it seems
overwhelmingly likely that Boris Johnson
will get a majority on Thursday telling
years of Tory government and another
five years to come if he gets a majority
it's quite sobering isn't that normal
expressing really that's why I was
interested in Moussa it brought him
yeah maybe we'll all need to move thank
you very much indeed the pool result was
labour will win the British general
election 36 percent of you 45% say
conservatives with just 19 seeing a hung
parliament that was 3169 do you know
what's funny about that yeah that almost
matter if you substitute the 19 percent
of people saying the Philby a hung
parliament for let's say the liberal and
brags a party percentages nationally
combined you actually have a poll that
isn't too different from what has or is
likely to be yes of all of the major
polling companies so there's something
to be said for that that is very
interesting indeed you're right 45 to
the tourist 36 to labour 19% being the
rest on rest also runs well look it's
been marvelous for me I hope it was for
you and if it was I hope you'll come
back at the same time next week
mercifully the defences of Moscow have
held and the cyber attackers have been
put to flight and I hope you've had an
enjoyable and uninterrupted flow of
opinion and fact and analysis and one of
two laughs on the mother of all talk
shows and if you did enjoy it please
tell just one other person because if
every one of you brings just one more
viewer or listener then we will be on an
audience of 1 million just think about
that see you next week God willing
[Music]